programming throwdown episode 55 editor wars take it away patrick well first i want to open up with a discussion about vacation. So it's the summer. People with children in school or in school themselves often think about vacation this time of year. I tend to actually be the opposite since I do have kids, but they're not school age. I try to take my vacations during the school year. And so that way it's cheaper and less crowded. And I'm basically a curmudgeonly old man. And then I came across an article about mandatory vacation and should it be required at tech companies. And there's an article we can link, but it got me thinking. And also I wanted to share, there was an interesting example in here where at bank companies, companies insured by the FDIC,
Programming Throwdown 第 55 期，编辑战争。Patrick，开始吧。好的，首先我想从度假的话题开始。现在是夏天，家里有孩子上学的人，或者自己还在上学的人，通常会在每年的这个时候考虑度假。我其实倾向于相反的做法，因为我虽然有孩子，但他们还没到上学的年龄。我尽量在学年中去度假，这样更便宜，人也更少。我基本上是个脾气暴躁的老头子。然后我偶然看到一篇文章，讨论强制休假以及科技公司是否应该强制要求员工休假。我们可以附上这篇文章的链接，但它让我开始思考。另外我想分享一下，文中有一个有趣的例子，在银行公司，也就是受 FDIC（联邦存款保险公司）承保的公司，
specifically the government has rules. And they say that you have to take at least two weeks of vacation per year for people in certain roles. And the reason being that if you're cooking the books at a financial institution, and you take a vacation for two weeks, that there's a much higher chance that someone will catch that the books are being cooked while you're gone. Because you have to kind of make edits on a daily basis to make everything match up in the ledgers and if you're gone for two weeks and someone else has to do that you'd have to collude with them um and so you know most of the time collusion is the risk is too high because you have you know we can get into game theory i guess but um there's a reason if you
具体来说，政府有相关规定。他们要求某些职位的员工每年至少休两周假。原因在于，如果你在金融机构做假账，而你休了两周假，那么在你离开期间，别人发现账目造假的可能性会大大增加。因为你必须每天进行编辑，让账目保持一致，如果你离开两周，别人不得不接手你的工作，你就必须与他们串通。嗯，所以你知道，大多数时候串通的风险太高了，因为你有……我想我们可以谈谈博弈论，但是……有一个原因，如果你
have if you have 100 people if any one of them defects the rule and then also if you have 100 people and someone breaks the rule you don't know which one and so yeah as soon as it gets more than one person it's very hard to which is also a convincing explanation i've heard about why conspiracy theories in general don't work is because they have too high of a rate of the defector problem like given the conspiracy someone would would defect at some point and you would know about it and it wouldn't be a conspiracy anymore. And so this is basically talking about that, you know, someone cooking the books and then they take a vacation and then the bank is able to notice it because the other person isn't cooking the books. And they weren't the person writing the article wasn't suggesting that the same thing is happening at tech companies but they had a good point which is if you force people to take at least two weeks every year consecutively away um that it forces code to be like maintainable and documented and i've noticed this before my team always freaks
有 100 个人，如果其中任何一个人违反了规则，而且如果有 100 个人，有人打破了规则，你却不知道是谁，所以是的，一旦超过一个人，就很难查出来。这也是我听到的关于为什么阴谋论通常行不通的一个令人信服的解释，因为它们有太高的背叛者问题发生率。鉴于阴谋的存在，总有人会在某个时刻背叛，你就会知道这件事，它就不再是阴谋了。所以这基本上是在谈论那个，你知道，有人做假账，然后他们去度假，银行就能发现，因为另一个人没有做假账。写这篇文章的人并不是建议科技公司也发生同样的事情，但他们提出了一个很好的观点，即如果你强制人们每年至少连续休两周假，这会迫使代码变得可维护且有文档记录。我以前注意到这一点，我的团队总是会抓狂，
out if i'm going to go on vacation for even a week like you know make sure everything's in order before you leave blah blah blah and then they never do anything while i'm gone because like a week isn't enough i don't even know if two weeks is enough actually, but it's probably more than one week where people have to do stuff while you're gone. And that requires the system to be capable of handling it because people could get sick or like going to the hospital or have a family emergency and be gone for two weeks. And so forcing each person in the company to be gone for at least two consecutive weeks would make sure that that regimen is followed in addition to the people going away not thinking about work for two weeks and coming back will just have like a renewed clarity to
如果我要去度假哪怕一周，你知道，确保在我离开之前一切就绪等等，然后我离开的时候他们什么都不做，因为一周时间不够。我甚至不知道两周是否真的够，但可能比一周要好，因为人们必须在你离开时处理事情。这要求系统有能力处理这种情况，因为人们可能会生病，或者去医院，或者有家庭紧急情况而离开两周。因此，强制公司里的每个人至少连续离开两周，将确保这种制度得到遵循，此外，离开的人两周不去想工作，回来后会对他们正在做的事情有焕然一新的清晰认识。
their mind about what they're working on thoughts yeah that makes sense i mean i think that as far as you know making your code kind of morefriendly and more developer-friendly, rotation is also good for that. Yeah, that's a good point. You don't want to be the guy on Team X for 10 years, and you know everything about Team X. And no matter how hard you try to document, there's always going to be something that you're so unconscious so unconsciously you're so unconsciously aware of that you know you don't document it and so as soon as you go on vacation or change teams everyone realizes oh we totally missed the the secret sauce that makes project x work and so um vacation is one way to do that rotating is another way but yeah i i know some people and you probably also
想法，是的，这很有道理。我的意思是，我认为就让你的代码更友好、对开发者更友好而言，轮岗也是有好处的。是的，这是一个很好的观点。你不想在 X 团队待上 10 年，而且你了解关于 X 团队的一切。无论你多么努力地记录，总会有一些东西是你潜意识里非常了解的，以至于你没有记录下来。所以一旦你去度假或换了团队，每个人都会意识到，哦，我们完全错过了让项目 X 运行的秘诀。所以，度假是一种方法，轮岗是另一种方法，但是的，我知道有些人，你可能也
patrick know people who never take vacation. Yes. There's a there's a max on vacation. At some point you stop accruing it. There's people who just like they lose vacation time. And that blows my mind. Like, I just I don't think I could focus if I went three years without a vacation. You know, sometimes I don't take vacation for a while and i really get like that
认识那些从不度假的人，Patrick。是的。度假是有上限的。在某个时候，你就不再积累假期了。有些人就是……他们浪费了假期。这让我很震惊。就像，我只是觉得如果我三年不度假，我就无法集中注意力。你知道，有时我有一段时间不度假，我真的会变得像那样，
like oh i really need to just take a day away or two days away but then other times you know i feel like i go long stretches where i'm okay and if the work is engaging and not overstressing um yeah i i do i also don't end up ever running out um and it depends on your company too like how many weeks of vacation and the other thing i found is that different companies, if they have like less vacation that you're able to take whenever you want and more like company given vacation, like, Oh, we're going to give you this week of Christmas off. So, you know, we're going to give you less vacation because we give you this week of Christmas off.
就像，哦，我真的需要请一天或两天假。但有时，你知道，我觉得我会有很长一段时间状态还行，如果工作很有吸引力且没有过度压力的话。嗯，是的，我最终也不会用完假期。这也取决于你的公司，比如有多少周的假期。我发现的另一件事是，不同的公司，如果他们提供的假期较少，让你随时可以休，而更多的是公司规定的假期，比如，“哦，我们要给你圣诞节这一周假。”所以，你知道，我们给你的假期会少一些，因为我们给了你圣诞节这一周假。
Like that matters too, because you can't decide when to take your vacation. Um, and so different companies have different like balances of how they give their vacation and i think that plays a lot as well yeah that makes sense but it would be interesting to have to be away for two weeks in a row but i wouldn't like to be told that i had to take all my vacation at once yeah i actually i've always taken just kind of small like little mini vacations but a lot of them like you know two or three a year um yeah i mean taking two weeks and it would be kind of weird yeah i think it would be kind of weird to be gone for a whole two weeks but i think they
这也很重要，因为你不能决定什么时候休假。嗯，所以不同的公司在提供假期的方式上有不同的平衡，我认为这也有很大影响。是的，这很有道理，但如果必须连续离开两周会很有趣，但我不想被告知必须一次性休完所有假期。是的，其实我一直都是休那种小型的迷你假期，但次数很多，你知道，一年两三次。嗯，我的意思是，休两周假会有点奇怪。是的，我觉得离开整整两周会有点奇怪，但我认为他们
have good points about making sure you're i think there's a belief amongst a lot of people that the best way to assure your value to the company and to get paid the most or whatever is be irreplaceable that no one knows what you're doing oh they know what you're doing but no one knows how to do it and so they have to keep paying you and keep you around or else everything would crumble but i feel like that's a very fragile system that people i don't think that's sustainable it does work for some people i can't deny it but i've seen more people be successful at being like over communicating documenting everything making the system so anyone could run it and then i think people
有很好的观点，关于确保你是……我认为很多人有一种信念，即确保你对公司的价值并获得最高报酬或什么的最好方法是变得不可替代，没有人知道你在做什么。哦，他们知道你在做什么，但没有人知道怎么做，所以他们必须继续付钱给你并留住你，否则一切都会崩溃。但我感觉那是一个非常脆弱的系统，我不认为那是可持续的。它对某些人确实有效，我不能否认，但我见过更多人通过过度沟通、记录一切、使系统任何人都能运行而获得成功，然后我认为人们
companies long term do value that um yeah right and that gets rewarded higher than the guy who keeps all the secrets or lady who keeps all the secrets yeah yeah totally all right cool uh onto news so i have the first link i this is a good resource and i know so a lot of you are probably um i don't know this will be helpful but many of you i know are learning programming and with learning programming at least for me they were tied together is when i first learned programming is when i first started encounter linux um way back in the day no um yeah what was your first linux i don't even remember now i i guess it would have been i think probably some sort of the early fedora yeah uh i think i think it's the same for me it was mandrake which uh or i actually don't know what happened to me
公司从长远来看确实重视这一点。嗯，是的，没错，这比那些保守秘密的人得到的奖励更高。是的，完全正确。好的，酷，进入新闻。所以我有了第一个链接，这是一个很好的资源，我知道你们很多人可能……我不知道这是否有帮助，但你们很多人我知道正在学习编程，而学习编程对我来说，它们是联系在一起的。我第一次学习编程时，就是我第一次接触 Linux 的时候，很久以前了。不，嗯，是的，你的第一个 Linux 是什么？我现在甚至不记得了。我猜可能是某种早期的 Fedora。是的，嗯，我想对我来说也是一样，是 Mandrake，或者……我其实不知道我发生了什么，
it wouldn't have been called fedora at the time i guess it would have still been red i don't remember how the open source thing they changed like fedora and red hat and i don't remember but one of those flavors oh i see apparently mandrake is now called uh mandriva but i guess it's still going oh no sorry the last release was four years ago so yeah um but but they were kind of tied closely together and i will say that for a lot of programming tasks that aside from application programming but if you're doing like system level programming linux seems to be the a necessary requirement at some point you'll come across it and um this website linuxjourney.com has a very nice organization of topics and then like little i've seen this style more and more
当时它不叫 Fedora，我猜它可能还是 Red Hat。我不记得他们是怎么改变开源的东西了，比如 Fedora 和 Red Hat，我不记得了，但其中一个版本。哦，我明白了，显然 Mandrake 现在叫 Mandriva，但我猜它还在运行。哦，不，抱歉，最后一次发布是四年前了。所以，是的，嗯……但它们是紧密联系在一起的，我会说对于很多编程任务，除了应用编程之外，如果你在做系统级编程，Linux 似乎是一个必要的条件，在某个时候你会遇到它。嗯，这个网站 linuxjourney.com 对主题的组织非常好，然后像……我越来越多地看到这种风格，
now i don't actually know what it's called but like wiki books or whatever where it's like topics on the left and then you and then you're reading the text on the right and it's it's a way to navigate a book and they have a whole bunch of resources along with like quizzes and like highlights about various topics in the linux operating system like how to search what is the boot process like um how how does piping work there's all sorts of different little topics and i feel like there's a lot to learn there and everyone makes linux out to be like very very hard and i and it's just one of those things that depends on how you're using it and what depth you need to go to but if you're trying to learn linux or you found yourself stuck or just looking for another resource because i know it for a long time it baffled me and i never really kind of got it and i'm still not like there are there's those
现在我其实不知道它叫什么，但像 Wiki 书之类的，左边是主题，然后你在右边阅读文本，这是一种浏览书籍的方式。他们有大量的资源，还有测验和关于 Linux 操作系统中各种主题的重点，比如如何搜索，启动过程是什么样的，管道是如何工作的，有各种各样不同的小主题。我觉得那里有很多东西要学，每个人都把 Linux 说得非常非常难，我……这只是取决于你如何使用它以及你需要深入到什么程度。但如果你正在尝试学习 Linux，或者发现自己卡住了，或者只是在寻找另一个资源，因为我知道它困扰了我很长时间，我从来没有真正理解它，而且我现在仍然不是……有那些
linux people and i'm very happy that they're around and i always like to make sure one's like within arm's reach of me um but that's it's never been me um but now i you know i i'm know enough to hurt myself and probably not enough to help myself out of the problems um yeah i'm in the same boat i mean i've i'm still getting to the point where i get things like kind of really hosed and i have to reinstall but But yeah, I think it's an incredibly useful skill. I mean, there's a lot of useful things for programmers to know just by going through Linux. Like, for example, the idea that there are these pipes and instead of using the console to print debug statements, you actually write your result to the console, and you read your result from what's called standard in, which is the console input.
Linux 大神，我很高兴他们存在，我总是喜欢确保身边有一个人……但那从来不是我。但现在，你知道，我知道的足够让自己陷入麻烦，可能不足以让自己摆脱问题。嗯，是的，我和你一样。我的意思是，我仍然会遇到那种把事情搞得一团糟，不得不重新安装的情况。但是，是的，我认为这是一项非常有用的技能。我的意思是，程序员通过学习 Linux 可以学到很多有用的东西。例如，有管道（pipes）的概念，而不是使用控制台打印调试语句，你实际上将结果写入控制台，并从所谓的标准输入（standard in）读取结果，也就是控制台输入。
And if you do that and you abide by a few laws, then you can be part of the Unix stack. So someone can do LS, pipe it to grep and then pipe it to xargs and then pipe it to your program and it would just work. It's just kind of magic. So it's definitely incredibly useful. And yeah, this tutorial looks awesome. Yes, there's a lot of good
如果你这样做并遵守一些规则，那么你就可以成为 Unix 栈的一部分。所以有人可以执行 LS，通过管道传给 grep，然后传给 xargs，然后传给你的程序，它就能直接运行。这简直就像魔法一样。所以它绝对是非常有用的。而且，是的，这个教程看起来很棒。是的，有很多好的
stuff in there and hopefully that'll be a good resource to you because it is a tough topic and even just knowing what you don't know. So this one's cool because as opposed to finding on Stack Overflow how to do something, which is also very useful, this kind of gives you this things you should be looking for as you advance in your Linux skills. Yep. So yeah, my news is OpenAI Gym. This is pretty cool. It's like a set of benchmarks for a machine learning AI algorithm. But the benchmarks are all kind of cool to watch.
东西在里面，希望这对你来说是一个很好的资源，因为它是一个很难的主题，甚至只是知道你不知道什么。所以这个很酷，因为与在 Stack Overflow 上寻找如何做某事（这也很有用）相比，这为你提供了随着 Linux 技能提升你应该寻找的东西。是的。所以，是的，我的新闻是 OpenAI Gym。这非常酷。它是一组用于机器学习 AI 算法的基准测试。但这些基准测试看起来都很酷。
I mean, there's one where it plays Breakout. It's also called Arkanoid, which is this game where you're a little, like a little, I guess, rectangle, and there's this ball, and you to like bounce the ball off the ceiling um there's like all these other atari games there's there's actually doom so you can have an ai that plays doom and usually when you do these kind of things like there's a starcraft ai competition and things like that that aren't part of the gym but but these other competitions um it's always like such a hack I mean think about it you have to you know write some AI and then
我的意思是，有一个它玩 Breakout 的例子。它也叫 Arkanoid，就是那个你是一个小……我想是一个小矩形，有一个球，你必须让球从天花板上弹回来……还有所有这些其他的 Atari 游戏，甚至还有 Doom。所以你可以有一个玩 Doom 的 AI。通常当你做这类事情时，比如有星际争霸 AI 竞赛之类的，它们不是 Gym 的一部分，但这些其他的竞赛……它总是像是一个黑客行为。我的意思是，想想看，你必须，你知道，写一些 AI，然后
force that AI into Starcraft without having any kind of API or anything it's just it's very hacky and so these guys have done kind of all the hacky things for you and so um they provide a very nice api where it's it just says something like here's a picture of the screen the the the like what you would see if you were playing doom um and then maybe they even give you extra hints uh like you know a actual location where the enemies are um so you don't have to do any image processing or anything and and you build the ai on top of their api and they another thing is really cool is they have examples so you can actually um i think one of them is like a deep neural network that can play these games and so you can you can download this github project and you can train it on your computer um and then uh when it's done training you have this
强行把那个 AI 塞进星际争霸里，没有任何 API 或其他东西，这非常业余。所以这些人已经为你做了所有那些业余的事情。所以，嗯，他们提供了一个非常好的 API，它只是说类似“这是屏幕的图片，如果你在玩 Doom 时会看到什么”，然后也许他们甚至给你额外的提示，比如，你知道，敌人所在的实际位置，所以你不需要做任何图像处理之类的。然后你在他们的 API 之上构建 AI。他们另一件非常酷的事情是他们有示例，所以你可以，嗯，我想其中一个是深度神经网络，可以玩这些游戏。所以你可以下载这个 GitHub 项目，并在你的电脑上训练它。然后，当训练完成后，你就有了这个
like doom ai or this atari ai that's like pretty powerful so yeah this is this is super cool if you're an ai enthusiast definitely check it out even if you're not uh they have you know step-by-step installation instructions like if you just want to see an ai play one of these games um you can follow the instructions without being an ai wizard or anything and you can have a something that actually works it's pretty sweet i think it's interesting the people talk about ai development in games but it's different writing the ai like you're talking about where you're simulating the player and the interface is you know the screen and you have to do image processing or maybe they give you something a little more and writing like in doom like the
像 Doom AI 或 Atari AI，它非常强大。所以，是的，这超级酷。如果你是 AI 爱好者，一定要看看。即使你不是，嗯，他们有，你知道，分步安装说明。如果你只是想看一个 AI 玩这些游戏，你可以按照说明操作，而不需要成为 AI 大师，你就可以拥有一个真正能运行的东西。这很棒。我认为人们谈论游戏中的 AI 开发很有趣，但编写 AI 的方式不同，就像你说的，你在模拟玩家，界面是，你知道，屏幕，你必须做图像处理，或者也许他们给你更多一点东西。而编写像 Doom 里的
bad guy ai and the bad guy ai you know they the programmers have the opportunity to expose any variables from the world they want to to that ai to help it operate and you know could in effect cheat and then even turn down the cheating for different different difficulties but as the ai you're talking about you don't have that level of access especially not if it's not implemented by the game itself yeah right um yeah i i think actually the ai of the enemies is is kind of interesting i mean if you think about it, like in Mario, if the enemies had some clever AI, that game would be so hard. Like, I mean, all the turtles and the Goombas,
坏蛋 AI，坏蛋 AI，你知道，程序员有机会向那个 AI 暴露世界中的任何变量来帮助它操作，你知道，实际上可以作弊，甚至可以为不同的难度调低作弊程度。但作为你谈论的 AI，你没有那种访问权限，特别是如果它不是由游戏本身实现的话。是的，没错。嗯，是的，我其实认为敌人的 AI 很有趣。我的意思是，如果你想想看，比如在马里奥里，如果敌人有一些聪明的 AI，那个游戏会变得非常难。我的意思是，所有的乌龟和板栗仔，
like they would just band together. I mean, I guess some of them are trapped by the terrain, but they would just band together and just stack up or like fall on you when you try and jump onto this pipe and just kill you, you know? And so that game only works because all of the individual patterns of the enemies are very simple like if all the enemies
它们会联合起来。我的意思是，我猜它们中的一些被地形困住了，但它们会联合起来，堆叠在一起，或者当你试图跳上这个管道时掉在你身上，直接杀了你，你知道吗？所以那个游戏之所以能玩，是因为所有敌人的个体模式都非常简单。如果所有的敌人
moved randomly it just like it'd be so hard and so it's it's kind of interesting um the whole ai problem for you know the the game agents themselves is super interesting for like a different reason but yeah i mean this is all about being able to to play the games and uh and uh that's like a a different kind of problem but still kind of interesting in its own right i see a lot of stuff for um games like real-time strategy and stuff about whether the ai can quote unquote cheat because there's this notion like if you're in and stuff about whether the ai can quote unquote cheat because there's this notion like if you're in civilization or whatever and the computer knows you're taking a certain path they could kind of choose something that is strong against that path
随机移动，它会变得非常难。所以这很有趣。嗯，整个 AI 问题，对于，你知道，游戏代理本身来说，出于不同的原因超级有趣。但是的，我的意思是，这一切都是关于能够玩游戏，而且，嗯，这是一个不同类型的问题，但本身也很有趣。我看到很多关于，嗯，像即时战略游戏之类的东西，关于 AI 是否可以“引用”作弊，因为有这种概念，比如如果你在文明之类的游戏中，电脑知道你正在采取某条路径，它们可以某种程度上选择一些对该路径很强的东西，
and thereby creating a harder ai but in a way that if you played another human they wouldn't be able to do the same thing or at least not with certainty and so you can kind of fake having a harder ai by just allowing the ai to cheat yeah definitely and civilization is notorious for this but you know they also didn't have many resources and you know i guess the 90s when civ one came out but even that is still an interesting thing is to say that like understanding the game in a way that you can even figure out with all the information known in the world how do you not just make some opponent that will win because you could just like spawn an infinite number of enemies or something like but that's not interesting but you know something that looks like it's behaving normally even though
从而创造一个更难的 AI，但以一种如果你和另一个人玩，他们无法做到同样事情的方式，或者至少不能确定地做到。所以你可以通过允许 AI 作弊来伪造一个更难的 AI。是的，绝对是这样，文明在这方面很有名。但你知道，他们也没有多少资源，你知道，我猜 90 年代文明 1 出来的时候。但即使是这样，这也是一件有趣的事情，即理解游戏的方式，以至于你甚至可以用世界上已知的所有信息弄清楚，你如何不只是制造一个会赢的对手，因为你可以只是，比如生成无限数量的敌人之类的，但这并不有趣。但你知道，看起来像是在正常行为的东西，即使
it's has access to the world but what information from the world is it choosing to use and then still making it fun like it isn't fun if it just like kills you instantly because it has infinite health and you have you know normal health oh i see what you're saying um so you so you need to both be difficult but like in a way that feels like a challenge and feels fun at the end of the day and they have access to cheating by like making resources that you can't have or cheating by having the world's information but they still need to use it in a way that doesn't go overboard yeah you know what this reminds me there's one game that does something like this and it's um it's like a knockoff of guitar hero
它有权访问世界，但它选择使用世界中的什么信息，然后仍然让它变得有趣。比如，如果它只是因为有无限的生命值而立即杀死你，而你有，你知道，正常的生命值，那就不有趣了。哦，我明白了你的意思。嗯，所以你需要既困难，但又以一种感觉像挑战且最终感觉有趣的方式。他们可以通过制造你无法拥有的资源来作弊，或者通过拥有世界信息来作弊，但他们仍然需要以一种不过分的方式使用它。是的，你知道这让我想起了什么，有一个游戏做了类似的事情，它是……它就像是吉他英雄的仿制品，
i think it's called like bit trip beat or it's Audio Surf or one of these games. But basically, you can give it any MP3 you want and it will generate like a Guitar Hero kind of level for you. And you can even specify the difficulty. And so this is the kind of thing where, yeah, I mean, in this case, they have to sort of understand how the music relates to sort of these game patterns and then also be able to ramp up and down the difficulty. Yeah, I think these things are super, super hard to build. Yeah, I mean, and it's ultimately a game supposed to be fun. So you don't just have to make it and make it work, but you have to make it enjoyable at the end of the day. Yeah, right.
我想它叫 Bit Trip Beat，或者是 Audio Surf，或者是这些游戏之一。但基本上，你可以给它任何你想要的 MP3，它会为你生成类似吉他英雄的关卡。你甚至可以指定难度。所以这就是那种情况，是的，我的意思是，在这种情况下，他们必须某种程度上理解音乐如何与这些游戏模式相关联，然后还要能够提高和降低难度。是的，我认为这些东西超级超级难构建。是的，我的意思是，最终游戏应该是好玩的。所以你不只是要制造它并让它工作，你还得让它在最后变得令人愉快。是的，没错。
The next article I have here is learn docker by building a microservice if you hang out on any sort of web forum or reddit or hacker news or whatever you see docker all the time or at least i do yep and um i kind of never really got what it was um now i'm beginning to understand it but i came across this tutorial and i thought it was really well done um and you know i was like coming there's lots of tutorials and some of them are not very well done and but i appreciate people trying to make them but i also appreciate when someone does a really good job of making something that is pretty cool so this person shows you how to use docker and it's a tutorial about docker but they use a real world example of bringing up my sql database and node.js in a docker image or images i guess linking them together and then using it to actually bring up a essentially a website a web server and i thought this was
我这里的下一篇文章是“通过构建微服务学习 Docker”。如果你在任何类型的网络论坛、Reddit、Hacker News 或其他地方闲逛，你总是会看到 Docker，或者至少我看到了。是的，嗯，我从来没有真正理解它是什么。现在我开始理解它了，但我偶然发现了这个教程，我觉得它做得非常好。而且，你知道，我当时想，有很多教程，其中一些做得不是很好，但我感谢人们试图制作它们，但我也欣赏当有人真正做得很好，制作出非常酷的东西时。这个人向你展示了如何使用 Docker，这是一个关于 Docker 的教程，但他们使用了一个现实世界的例子，在 Docker 镜像（或镜像，我想）中启动 MySQL 数据库和 Node.js，将它们链接在一起，然后用它来实际启动一个本质上的网站、一个 Web 服务器。我觉得这
really good and it's really pertinent because it's something that i think we're seeing a lot more of docker get kind of um traction and there's other solutions but i think they're once you understand one it's in my mind so far at least they all seem similar enough and um this would be a great thing to learn if you're you know in school or applying for jobs or even if you're in a job and trying to see hey is this something that can actually help solve the problems at my company yeah i mean docker is definitely a hard thing to explain um i guess i mean i'll try and do it oh you're gonna try okay here we go i'll try um so well there's virtual machines which have been around for a while and that is where um you know you
非常好，而且非常贴切，因为我认为我们看到 Docker 越来越多地获得……牵引力，还有其他解决方案，但我认为一旦你理解了一个，在我看来，到目前为止，它们看起来都足够相似。而且，嗯，如果你在学校或申请工作，甚至如果你在工作中并试图看看，嘿，这是否真的是可以帮助解决我公司问题的东西，这将是一件很棒的学习内容。是的，我的意思是，Docker 绝对是一个很难解释的东西。我猜，我的意思是，我会试一试。哦，你要试一试，好的，我们开始吧。我会试一试。所以，嗯，有虚拟机，它们已经存在一段时间了，那就是，嗯，你知道，你
see people running like windows inside of their mac or the vice versa or linux inside of their windows machine right and so what that does is it pretends like you have sort of an os inside of an os uh or and so it actually when the virtual machine says you know i want to write to this part of this disk um that command goes to you know your your machine engine, like let's say VirtualBox or something. And VirtualBox translates that into a command on your host machine saying, oh, the person said they want to write to this part of the disk, but on the host machine, it's actually that part of that disk. And so right over there. And so it has to do this sort of translation.
看到人们在他们的 Mac 里运行 Windows，或者反之亦然，或者在他们的 Windows 机器里运行 Linux，对吧？所以它所做的是假装你在操作系统里有一个操作系统。或者，所以当虚拟机说，你知道，我想写入磁盘的这个部分时，那个命令会发送到，你知道，你的机器引擎，比如 VirtualBox 之类的。然后 VirtualBox 将其转换为宿主机上的命令，说，哦，那个人说他们想写入磁盘的这个部分，但在宿主机上，它实际上是那个磁盘的那个部分。所以就在那边。所以它必须做这种转换。
From what I understand, so like, let's say you had a Windows machine and you had a Windows VM. Then in that case, like you could make a lot of assumptions. Like, you know, you don't have to sort of translate everything. There's a lot of things that, like if you wanted to play a note, a music note on the VM, and you know that everything is Windows, you would just pass that command to the host and just say, hey, host, you know, play a music note. You wouldn't have to, like, do any translation. And so I think Docker sort of takes advantage of this. And correct me if I'm wrong, but I think you have to keep the same OS. You can't run, like, a Mac Docker oncker on windows right it doesn't really work like that and so granted that you want the same os docker gives you this whole environment that's self-contained but also very
据我所知，所以，比如，假设你有一台 Windows 机器，你有一个 Windows 虚拟机。那么在这种情况下，比如你可以做很多假设。比如，你知道，你不必某种程度上转换所有东西。有很多事情，比如如果你想在虚拟机上播放一个音符，一个音乐音符，而且你知道一切都是 Windows，你只会把那个命令传给宿主机，然后说，嘿，宿主机，你知道，播放一个音符。你不需要，比如，做任何转换。所以我认为 Docker 某种程度上利用了这一点。如果我错了请纠正我，但我认为你必须保持相同的操作系统。你不能运行，比如，Mac Docker 在 Windows 上，对吧？它不是那样工作的。所以，假设你想要相同的操作系统，Docker 给你提供了这个自包含的整个环境，但也非常
fast and gives you raw access to like the gpu and things like that uh you did a good job describing like emulators or at least like the os emulators like virtual box but i think the way i view docker is a little differently so you can so there's a windows version of docker and you can run linux vms in it and that's right but docker isn't really i don't know at least to me the interesting part isn't about running the vm um and there's a whole bunch of hard technology problems they're trying to solve but it's about this containerizing which is about saying yes i'm going to start a vm but i want a way of describing what should be in that vm so that it's repeatable so if you take an example like i want to i want to write a my sql database
快，并给你对 GPU 之类的东西的原始访问权限。嗯，你很好地描述了模拟器，或者至少像 VirtualBox 这样的操作系统模拟器。但我认为我看待 Docker 的方式有点不同。所以你可以……所以有一个 Windows 版本的 Docker，你可以在里面运行 Linux 虚拟机，那是对的。但 Docker 并不是真的……我不知道，至少对我来说，有趣的部分不是关于运行虚拟机。而且他们试图解决一大堆困难的技术问题，但它是关于这种容器化，也就是关于说，是的，我要启动一个虚拟机，但我想要一种描述那个虚拟机里应该有什么的方法，这样它是可重复的。所以如果你拿一个例子，比如我想……我想写一个 MySQL 数据库，
so i'm just something that's going to use my sql so i just download one of these packages install it and all of its dependencies on my machine. And I got MySQL running locally. And then I create my schema, I insert some data, and then I'm doing my testing. But then now I need to share that work with my coworker, then I need to tell them or remember how I did all of that and like get MySQL installed on their computer as well. And then remember if i had to like install any patches or anything weird um and so what docker kind of says at least in the in how i use it this is that does many things but is allows you to kind of create a text description saying i want to pull an ubuntu uh image down i want to in that ubuntu image run these commands to apt-get install these you know
所以我只是要使用 MySQL 的东西，所以我只是下载这些包之一，安装它以及它在我的机器上的所有依赖项。然后我在本地运行了 MySQL。然后我创建了我的模式，我插入了一些数据，然后我在做我的测试。但现在我需要与我的同事分享那个工作，然后我需要告诉他们或记住我是怎么做所有这些的，比如让他们也在他们的电脑上安装 MySQL。然后记住我是否必须，比如安装任何补丁或任何奇怪的东西。所以 Docker 某种程度上说，至少在我使用它的方式中，这是……它做了很多事情，但允许你某种程度上创建一个文本描述，说我想拉取一个 Ubuntu 镜像，我想在那个 Ubuntu 镜像中运行这些命令来 apt-get 安装这些，你知道，
services at this version then i want to start uh you know my sql service in that ubuntu thing or maybe you can just get a pre-packaged my sql docker container uh then i want to link it with a node.js container and so i'm running two vms as if they're running on two different machines but then i explicitly but initially they're not really connected to anything because you don't want something bad happening so you have to explicitly say here's how I want them to be talking to each other and then now as a developer if I get that working on my machine I can give it to my co-worker and they can also like give them the description and they can also have it bring up and do the same thing and then when ready to deploy to you know infrastructure that can be run on a server. So the server can pull down that, that those
服务在这个版本，然后我想启动，你知道，那个 Ubuntu 里的 MySQL 服务，或者也许你可以直接得到一个预打包的 MySQL Docker 容器。然后我想把它与一个 Node.js 容器链接起来。所以我运行了两个虚拟机，就好像它们在两台不同的机器上运行一样。但随后我明确地……但最初它们并没有真正连接到任何东西，因为你不希望发生坏事。所以你必须明确地说，这是我希望它们如何相互交谈的方式。然后现在作为一个开发者，如果我在我的机器上让它工作，我可以把它给我的同事，他们也可以，比如给他们描述，他们也可以让它启动并做同样的事情。然后当准备好部署到，你知道，基础设施时，它可以在服务器上运行。所以服务器可以拉取那个，那些
descriptions build the images and run those services in production, just like we were in development. And it kind of is a way of having a containerized thing that describes all of that manages the packages, manages the workflow and says how these things should be built so that they're repeatable and deployable and you don't have to do this notion of dependence keeping dependencies in sync across all your machines because you're kind of listing them all together i see that makes sense uh so i probably butchered some of it as well um but it does that by using a vm like you were indicating. But I think like in the production ideas,
描述，构建镜像并在生产环境中运行这些服务，就像我们在开发中一样。它是一种拥有容器化事物的方式，它描述了所有这些，管理包，管理工作流，并说明这些东西应该如何构建，以便它们是可重复和可部署的，你不需要做这种在所有机器上保持依赖项同步的概念，因为你某种程度上把它们都列在一起了。我明白了，这很有道理。嗯，所以我可能也搞砸了一些。但它确实是通过使用虚拟机来做到这一点的，就像你指出的那样。但我认为，比如在生产想法中，
you want the host operating system to be a very, very minimal thing that's optimized just for running other VMs. And there's, they call these like hypervisors or other things. And then each, you know, kind of image, you want to be as minimal as possible because you don't need a lot of stuff.
你希望宿主操作系统是一个非常非常小的东西，专门为运行其他虚拟机而优化。而且有，他们称这些为管理程序或其他东西。然后每个，你知道，某种镜像，你希望尽可能小，因为你不需要很多东西。
It's each container is supposed to kind of only do one thing. And that's why as this article insinuates, it's really good for microservices, where instead of a monolithic application, you build, you know, each service kind of individually, and then you they depend on each other, but they're not all one thing. And that has a lot of opportunities. It has some downsides, too. And maybe we could get into that at some point. But it is interesting approach and it does work for a lot of people yeah this is cool so i guess i mean if you're running two docker images and let's say one of them is your mysql database and that that mysql database blows up like there's some bug in mysql and it just gets out of control then like at least the other docker image can just say oh the database is blowing up
每个容器应该某种程度上只做一件事。这就是为什么正如这篇文章所暗示的那样，它非常适合微服务，而不是单体应用程序，你构建，你知道，每个服务某种程度上是独立的，然后它们相互依赖，但它们不是一个整体。这有很多机会。它也有一些缺点。也许我们可以在某个时候讨论这个问题。但这是一个有趣的方法，它确实对很多人有效。是的，这很酷。所以我想，我的意思是，如果你运行两个 Docker 镜像，假设其中一个是你的 MySQL 数据库，而那个 MySQL 数据库崩溃了，比如 MySQL 中有一些错误，它失控了，那么至少另一个 Docker 镜像可以说，哦，数据库崩溃了，
let me tell like a 404 to the users or something instead of the whole machine blowing up yep so um yeah oh sorry yes yeah i mean there's lots of reasons to do that but yeah i think that is a good reason yeah cool so my new story is fizz buzz in tensor flow this is uh this is a kind of a troll like a trollish uh story but it's pretty funny basically um there's this pro there's this interview question called fizz buzz and uh the idea is you print the numbers from one to a hundred um but the number is visible by 3, you print fizz. If the number is visible by 5, you print buzz. And if it's 15, you print fizz buzz.
让我告诉用户一个 404 之类的，而不是整个机器崩溃。是的，所以，嗯，是的，哦，抱歉，是的，是的，我的意思是，有很多理由这样做，但是的，我认为这是一个很好的理由。是的，酷。所以我的新闻故事是“TensorFlow 中的 Fizz Buzz”。这是，嗯，这是一个有点像钓鱼的……钓鱼的故事，但它很有趣。基本上，嗯，有一个问题，面试问题叫 Fizz Buzz。嗯，这个想法是你打印从 1 到 100 的数字，但如果数字能被 3 整除，你打印 Fizz。如果数字能被 5 整除，你打印 Buzz。如果它是 15，你打印 Fizz Buzz。
So if it's none of those, then you print the number. So, for example, it would be 1, 2, fizz, 4, buzz, so on and so forth, right? So this is like highly ridiculed as, you know, like a prime example of what not to do in a programming interview. Like what kind of questions not to ask. And there's just so many reasons. One, because so many other people have asked it. Two, because it doesn't really show kind of architectural skill or anything like that. There's a ton of reasons. And so this guy, Joel Gross, was in an interview.
所以如果它都不是，那么你打印数字。所以，例如，它会是 1, 2, Fizz, 4, Buzz，以此类推，对吧？所以这被高度嘲笑为，你知道，编程面试中不该做什么的典型例子。比如不该问什么样的问题。而且原因太多了。第一，因为太多其他人问过它了。第二，因为它并没有真正展示某种架构技能之类的东西。原因有很多。所以这个人，Joel Gross，在一次面试中。
I don't know if the article is real. No, no, no, because he's using it to explain. He's using it to explain TensorFlow. Yeah, the article is not real. There's no way on a whiteboard you would do this. The article is not real, but it's funny to just put yourself into this space and imagine this really happening. So in the article, an interviewer asks him to do FizzBuzz.
我不知道这篇文章是否真实。不，不，不，因为他用它来解释。他用它来解释 TensorFlow。是的，这篇文章不是真的。在白板上你不可能这样做。这篇文章不是真的，但把自己置身于这个空间并想象这真的发生很有趣。所以在文章中，面试官让他做 Fizz Buzz。
And so what he does is he spins up tensorflow which he talked about in the past sensorflow is a google created um you know tensor matrix library that has a lot of um you know objective functions loss functions all sorts of like things for building machine learning algorithms uh in already included. And so he spins up TensorFlow and he builds a neural network to solve the fizzbuzz problem. And the interviewer is just kind of, you know, like, what are you doing? And he just, you know, just kind of goes through the whole fizzbuzz thing. And then at the end he says, you know i didn't get the job
所以他做的是，他启动了 TensorFlow，他过去谈论过，TensorFlow 是谷歌创建的，嗯，你知道，张量矩阵库，它有很多，嗯，你知道，目标函数、损失函数，各种各样用于构建机器学习算法的东西，已经包含在内了。所以他启动了 TensorFlow，并构建了一个神经网络来解决 Fizz Buzz 问题。面试官只是某种程度上，你知道，就像，你在做什么？而他只是，你知道，只是某种程度上完成了整个 Fizz Buzz 的事情。然后在最后他说，你知道，我没得到那份工作。
um you know thanks a lot machine learning it's just it's just really goofy and funny if you want to have like a nice light-hearted read and learn how neural networks work and learn tensorflow um check this out at the end he posts the code on github so so uh it's not all in vain um check it out it's pretty good i think fizzbuzz isn't a bad question i know it does have kind of a bad rap because a lot of people have used it but i think in general just with interview questions it's difficult you need to know as an interviewer like what you're trying to get out of the interview and i think a lot of people don't know that well they do know they're trying to stroke their ego um but that's that's my cynical criticism of
嗯，你知道，多谢了，机器学习。这只是，它只是非常愚蠢和有趣。如果你想读一些轻松愉快的东西，学习神经网络是如何工作的，并学习 TensorFlow，看看这个。在最后，他在 GitHub 上发布了代码。所以，嗯，这一切并非徒劳。看看吧，它相当不错。我认为 Fizz Buzz 不是一个坏问题。我知道它确实名声不好，因为很多人用过它，但我认为总的来说，对于面试问题，这很困难。作为面试官，你需要知道你试图从面试中得到什么，而且我认为很多人不知道这一点。好吧，他们确实知道，他们试图满足自己的虚荣心，但这是我愤世嫉俗的批评，
it um but a lot of people don't know what they're trying to get out and i think fizzbuzz does work for saying i'm looking for someone who i'm looking for an easy way to test if someone knows basic coding skills it's not supposed to be algorithmically hard or architecturally hard um and it does that now whether or not that's useful to the company that you're interviewing for tbd and this person yes i agree i'm certain this is a joke that this did not actually happen that they were trying to be facetious and saying that they could use a neural network to figure it out but but also interesting because maybe for any such pattern producing algorithm in an interview you could do this. Yeah, yeah.
嗯，但很多人不知道他们试图得到什么，而且我认为 Fizz Buzz 确实有效，因为它说我正在寻找一个简单的方法来测试某人是否具备基本的编码技能。它不应该是算法上困难或架构上困难的。而且它做到了这一点。现在，这对于你面试的公司是否有用，待定。而这个人，是的，我同意，我肯定这是一个笑话，这并没有真正发生，他们试图变得滑稽，说他们可以使用神经网络来弄清楚它。但这也很有趣，因为也许对于面试中的任何这种模式生成算法，你都可以这样做。是的，是的。
I always wondered, you know, I used to do these programming contests, and I wondered for some of the harder problems if teams picked, like maybe not a neural network, but if they picked like any of these sort of heuristic, like any of these like loss function, objective-based approaches, and then just submitted the problem, you know, five times until they got the right answer, like with different random seeds.
我一直想知道，你知道，我过去常参加这些编程竞赛，我想知道对于一些更难的问题，如果团队选择了，比如可能不是神经网络，但如果他们选择了类似这些启发式的方法，比如任何这些损失函数、基于目标的方法，然后只是提交问题，你知道，五次，直到他们得到正确的答案，比如用不同的随机种子。
You could, I mean, the other thing is, because a lot of those have requirements on the runtime, but you could train for a very long time. So you could, you know, train offline, or even I've seen some solutions which they try to prevent, but you build up a dictionary ahead of time. So you spend a really long time with an inefficient algorithm building up a dictionary. And then when you submit a really long time with an inefficient algorithm building up a dictionary and then when you submit it it basically knows
你可以，我的意思是，另一件事是，因为其中许多对运行时间有要求，但你可以训练很长时间。所以你可以，你知道，离线训练，或者我甚至见过一些解决方案，他们试图防止这种情况，但你提前建立一个字典。所以你花很长时间用低效的算法建立一个字典。然后当你提交它时，它基本上就知道了。
all of the answers already or at least oh yeah that's a very common that might be less common now but uh yeah definitely when i was doing competitions that happened frequently so you could in theory train the neural network very slowly for a very long time and then at runtime it goes very fast where you don't know you don't know of a runtime algorithm that could run fast enough to answer their question yep yep interesting i wonder how many would be solvable with that approach like if you went in solely with that being your strategy and you were just committed to knowing how to train neural networks that way really fast like how many of the questions would be capable of even being approached and then how many you could actually get good answers with yeah i mean to answer it you have to know like how many of those problems are just a composition of functions
所有答案都已经有了，或者至少，哦对，这非常常见，虽然现在可能没那么常见了，但当我参加比赛时，这种情况确实经常发生。所以理论上，你可以非常缓慢地训练神经网络很长时间，然后在运行时它会运行得非常快，而你却不知道有什么运行时算法能快到足以回答他们的问题。是的，很有趣。我想知道有多少问题可以用这种方法解决，比如如果你完全把这作为你的策略，并且你致力于学习如何以那种方式非常快速地训练神经网络，那么有多少问题是甚至可以尝试的，然后有多少问题你能真正得到好的答案。是的，我的意思是，要回答这个问题，你必须知道这些问题中有多少仅仅是函数的组合。
versus how many are real simulations like there are these questions like you know play a game of tetris like and you have to actually drop the pieces and figure out what spaces are valid. And anything that has some kind of simulation aspect to it, you're not going to be able to do with a neural net. But if it's like some of these more geometric problems, where it's just like, you know, here's a bunch of angles, and you have to find this type of angle, then, yeah, some kind of neural net could probably do pretty well.
而有多少是真正的模拟。比如有一些问题，你知道，玩一局俄罗斯方块，你必须实际放下棋子并找出哪些空间是有效的。任何带有某种模拟性质的东西，你都无法用神经网络来完成。但如果是一些更几何的问题，比如，你知道，这里有一堆角度，你必须找到这种类型的角度，那么，是的，某种神经网络可能做得相当不错。
All right, time for book of the show. Book of the show. So I actually have a bunch of books. What? But here's the catch. There's only covers. So this is parody O'Reilly book covers. So for people who don't know, there's a publisher called O'Reilly.
好了，节目推荐书的时间到了。节目推荐书。其实我有一堆书。什么？但问题在于，只有封面。所以这些是恶搞的 O'Reilly 书籍封面。所以对于不知道的人来说，有一家出版商叫 O'Reilly。
They publish a ton of different books, everything from HTML website design to game programming to Lua. They have books on everything. And they all have sort of this similar cover style where there's usually some picture of some animal that's in this kind of pencil charcoal sketch style um some kind of headline at the top and then some type of adjective which never really makes sense but it's just kind of you know there and then a big title and so um
他们出版了大量的书籍，从 HTML 网站设计到游戏编程，再到 Lua。他们什么书都有。而且它们都有某种相似的封面风格，通常会有一张某种动物的图片，采用这种铅笔炭笔素描风格，顶部有某种标题，然后是某种形容词，虽然从来没什么意义，但它就在那儿，然后是一个大标题，所以……
this guy made a bunch of parody o'reilly book covers and they're absolutely hilarious um just just to give you guys uh some spoilers here one is a essential copying and pasting from stack overflow very useful putting the candidate through the same junk you went through useless whiteboard interviews yes useless whiteboard interview book um expert resume driven development oh this is good okay well anyways these are all these these are funny yeah i want to follow them all actually i'm thinking about getting a t-shirt with that with one of these um i don't know it's bad i think it's that okay all right the whiteboard interviews i think i i want a t-shirt of the whiteboard
这家伙做了一堆恶搞的 O'Reilly 书籍封面，它们绝对非常搞笑。为了给你们剧透一下，一个是《从 Stack Overflow 复制粘贴的精髓》，非常有用；《让候选人经历你经历过的同样垃圾》，无用的白板面试；是的，无用的白板面试书；《专家简历驱动开发》，哦，这很好。好吧，总之这些都很有趣。是的，我其实想关注他们所有人。我正在考虑买一件印有其中一个封面的 T 恤。我不知道，这很糟糕，我觉得这很好。好吧，白板面试，我想买一件白板面试的 T 恤。
interviews for when I give interviews I want to be wearing this shirt I want to just have it at my desk and put it on, give the interview and then take it back off have you read the twitter feed entitled tech worker?
当我面试别人时，我想穿这件衬衫。我想把它放在我的办公桌上，穿上它，进行面试，然后再脱下来。你读过那个叫“有权势的科技工作者”（Entitled Tech Worker）的 Twitter 账号吗？
it's somebody who obviously lives in the bay area the san francisco bay area and um works at one of the big tech companies so they have like kind of sarcastic entitled reasons why things are bad at their company um like i'm upset today's menu at work was all mexican i just got back yesterday from my via in puerto vallarta why does the new macbook pro why does why doesn't the new macbook pro come in gold oh man that's awesome oh this is really good entitled tech worker yeah if i knew the espresso machine was broken i would have asked my uber to stop at four barrel this is i mean if you're in the bear so this will make a lot more sense a lot of these are specific to the san francisco area well if you watch uh the tv show then then yeah you'll find these hilarious sometimes i don't even wait to agree on a linkedin endorsement
那是一个显然住在湾区、旧金山湾区，并且在一家大型科技公司工作的人。所以他们有一些关于为什么他们公司的事情很糟糕的讽刺性、有权势的理由。比如，“我很不高兴，今天工作的菜单全是墨西哥菜，我昨天才从巴亚尔塔港的别墅回来。”“为什么新款 MacBook Pro 没有金色的？”哦天哪，这太棒了。哦，这真的很好，“有权势的科技工作者”。是的，如果我知道浓缩咖啡机坏了，我会让我的 Uber 在 Four Barrel 停一下。我的意思是，如果你在湾区，这会更有意义。很多这些都是针对旧金山地区的。好吧，如果你看了那个电视节目，那么是的，你会觉得这些非常搞笑。有时候我甚至不等 LinkedIn 的互荐方案达成一致。
swapping scheme i just go out there and endorse people i don't even know that's so i only joined your company last week but i think it's already gone downhill my startup may have failed but my self-congratulatory blog post reached number one on hacker news oh man these are amazing okay i'll put a i'll add a link to these um in in the news whoever writes these is so very in touch with the culture genius uh um that's awesome all right my book is a uh fictional book hard magic by larry korea i don't know if that's how you say his last name um but he i also had a recommendation from him before i talked about uh his book monster hunters international so this is another um it's
我就直接去推荐那些我根本不认识的人。这太……我上周才加入你们公司，但我认为它已经走下坡路了。我的创业公司可能失败了，但我的自我吹捧博客文章在 Hacker News 上排名第一。哦天哪，这些太棒了。好吧，我会把链接加到新闻里。写这些的人非常了解这种文化，天才。那太棒了。好吧，我的书是一本虚构小说，《硬魔法》（Hard Magic），作者是拉里·科雷亚（Larry Correia）。我不知道他的姓是不是这么读，但他……我之前也收到过他的推荐，我谈论过他的书《怪物猎人国际》（Monster Hunter International）。所以这是另一本……
sort of similar like this is not a deep thoughtful book it's a kind of like really fun to read you kind of feel like it's just a like junk food book but it's good i liked it it's set in the i guess it'd be the 20s uh kind of like the mobster era and like uh alternate reality like what happens if around that time frame like magic had been discovered like you know how we have mixed scientific discoveries like you kind of discover magic and people start kind of having magical abilities it sounds really stupid but if you like stick with it and read it it actually is a fun read um but this author isn't really for everyone because he does spend a lot of like weirdly a lot of time describing various
有点类似，这不是一本深刻、发人深省的书，它是一种读起来非常有趣的书，你感觉它就像一本垃圾食品书，但它很好，我喜欢它。它的背景设定在，我想应该是 20 年代，那种黑帮时代，以及某种平行现实，比如如果在那段时间发现了魔法会发生什么，就像我们有混合科学发现一样，你发现了魔法，人们开始拥有魔法能力。这听起来很蠢，但如果你坚持读下去，它实际上是一本有趣的读物。但这位作者并不适合所有人，因为他确实花了很多奇怪的时间来描述书中的各种……
guns in the book like in in detail like oh this you know he's really into guns so every time there's a gun it's not just the person grabbed a gun they grabbed a very specific kind of gun um and so it's just interesting like that that's one of the things that he has a lot of detail about and i don't i'm pretty sure it's not very accurate to the 19 actual 1920s um but it is kind of interesting and it features like some of the work by nikola tesla and um other people and so i i enjoyed it like i said it wasn't the most thoughtful book i ever read or i mean i listened to it, but I did enjoy it. So if you're out there for a light, fun kind of listen,
枪支，非常详细，比如“哦，你知道，他真的很喜欢枪”，所以每次出现枪时，不仅仅是那个人抓起一把枪，他们抓起的是一种非常特定的枪。所以这很有趣，这是他有很多细节的地方之一。而且我很确定它对 1920 年代的描述不是很准确，但它确实有点意思，而且它还涉及尼古拉·特斯拉和其他人的一些工作，所以我很喜欢它。就像我说的，它不是我读过的最深刻的书，或者说，我是听的，但我确实很享受。所以如果你在寻找一种轻松、有趣的听物，
I would encourage you to check this out. I was going to ask you if it was like a cerebral book. No. Because at first I didn't know which way you were going. But yeah, so this is like lighthearted. It's not a complete comedy. Like I recommended, I think last time I recommended a book, it was Red Shirts, which was like purely just comedic i'm still going through that one it's okay so that one's
我会鼓励你看看这个。我本来想问你它是不是一本烧脑的书。不。因为起初我不知道你要往哪个方向走。但是的，所以这就像是轻松愉快的。它不是一部纯粹的喜剧。就像我推荐的，我想上次我推荐了一本书，是《红衫》（Red Shirts），那纯粹是喜剧。我还在读那一本，还可以，所以那一本是……
like really comedic this one has like i don't think it's meant to be funny like there are funny parts i guess but it's more just meant to be like uh you know you just watch like an action flick it isn't supposed to make you wonder about your have an existential crisis i did not have an existential crisis after reading this book that's good you didn't feel like you were actually a magician trapped well i did for a little bit but then i couldn't make the feather float with my wand and so yeah that's right yeah the fireball didn't work and uh yeah it ended badly uh anyways and like i said i listened to this and we've um audible has been
非常喜剧。这一本，我不认为它是为了搞笑，虽然我想有一些有趣的部分，但它更多是为了让你……你知道，就像看一部动作片，它不应该让你怀疑你的……经历存在危机。读完这本书后，我没有经历存在危机。那很好。你没有觉得自己真的被困在魔术师里了？好吧，我有一会儿是这么觉得的，但后来我没法用魔杖让羽毛漂浮起来，所以是的，就是这样。是的，火球术没起作用，而且是的，结局很糟糕。总之，就像我说的，我听了这本书，而且我们……Audible 一直是
a sponsor of the show and so if you go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown you can get a one month free trial which means you uh get a credit to have a book uh and then you can cancel it when you're done and keep the book and so if you've never checked them out before i have a long commute and i think you have a long commute now too, but I don't know commute. And so, um, I am a paying customer of theirs and have been for a while. And I really enjoy, uh, listening to the books. I don't enjoy the commute, but when I am like have an off day or like on a Saturday, it's kind of like, Oh, I didn't get to listen to my book today. Um, and so that's kind of a bummer, but check them out if you haven't already. And thank you a bunch of you already have. And so that's kind of a bummer. But check them out if you haven't already. And thank you. A bunch of you already have.
节目的赞助商，所以如果你去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以获得一个月的免费试用，这意味着你获得了一个积分来换取一本书，然后你可以在读完后取消它并保留这本书。所以如果你以前从未看过他们，我通勤时间很长，我想你现在通勤时间也很长，但我不知道。所以，我是他们的付费客户，已经有一段时间了。我真的很喜欢听书。我不喜欢通勤，但当我有空闲时间或者在周六时，我会觉得，“哦，我今天没能听我的书。”所以这有点遗憾，但如果你还没看过，去看看他们吧。而且感谢你们中已经有很多人这样做了。
And so I'm really thankful for you guys doing that. And if you got a book that you like and we haven't talked about, feel free to send us a recommendation. Somebody did. Somebody wrote in and recommended some Brandon Sanderson books. So we might talk about those in the future. Cool. Cool.
所以我真的很感谢你们这样做。如果你有一本你喜欢的书，而我们还没谈论过，请随时给我们发送推荐。有人写信推荐了一些布兰登·桑德森（Brandon Sanderson）的书。所以我们将来可能会谈论这些。酷。酷。
We're also on Patreon. And thank you for everyone who's been telling your friends someone randomly at work told me i had a friend of mine recommend this podcast to me programming throwdown i downloaded it and started listening to it and my jaw dropped when i heard your voice coming out of my earphones that's amazing so thank you guys for uh so at least one person told a friend about it um and thank you guys for spreading least one person told a friend about it. And thank you guys for spreading the word about Programming Throwdown and listening. That's right.
我们也在 Patreon 上。感谢每一位告诉朋友的人。有人在工作中随机告诉我，我有一个朋友向我推荐了这个播客，Programming Throwdown，我下载了它并开始听，当我听到你的声音从耳机里传出来时，我的下巴都惊掉了。这太棒了，所以谢谢你们……至少有一个人告诉了朋友。谢谢你们传播关于 Programming Throwdown 的消息并收听。没错。
This is not Fight Club. You can tell all your friends about it. Well, at least it's not the first rule. Yeah, that's right. We would probably get beat up in a street fight with almost anyone. All right. Tool of the show. Tool of the show. My tool of the show tool of the show my tool the show is amazing uh i have yet to use it like i'm actually so you only think it's a process well but i mean other people have used it and i know it works and so once i'm done getting through
这不是《搏击俱乐部》。你可以告诉所有的朋友。好吧，至少这不是第一条规则。是的，没错。我们可能在街头斗殴中会被几乎任何人打败。好了，节目工具时间。节目工具时间。我的节目工具……我的节目工具太棒了。我还没用过它，实际上……所以你只认为它是一个过程？好吧，但我的意思是其他人已经用过它了，我知道它有效，所以一旦我完成了……
uh the process i'm gonna be really happy so uh for the um the podcast i was paying for an ssl certificate and it's not that much money it's i think like 20 bucks a year or something like that um but basically a variety of companies um got together and said um let's make this free and and uh there's a there's actually a ton of companies here. I'm not going to list all of them, but just Mozilla is one of them, Electronic Frontier Foundation, so on and so forth. And they got together and they made this thing called Let's Encrypt. And the idea is it's just free SSL certificates that are meaningful, right?
这个过程，我会非常高兴。所以对于播客，我一直在支付 SSL 证书的费用，钱不多，我想一年大概 20 美元左右。但基本上，各种公司聚在一起说，“让我们把它免费吧。”而且实际上这里有很多公司。我不会列出所有公司，但 Mozilla 是其中之一，电子前沿基金会（Electronic Frontier Foundation），等等。他们聚在一起，做了这个叫 Let's Encrypt 的东西。它的理念就是免费的 SSL 证书，而且是有意义的，对吧？
They're not self-signed. They're signed and they're a trusted source and all of that. And so if you have a personal website, a business website, a small business website that's not encrypted, or if you're paying for encryption and you don't want to, you can use this Let's Encrypt. It's completely free and uh um there's not it's not like a beta free kind of thing like the plan the whole point of it is to be free forever um so it's it's amazing i mean it's it's it's uh and just to to recap if you don't know i'm sure everyone knows this but just in case um you know When you go to a website, there's HTTP and there's HTTPS.
它们不是自签名的。它们是经过签名且来源可信的。所以如果你有一个个人网站、商业网站、小型商业网站没有加密，或者如果你正在为加密付费但不想付，你可以使用这个 Let's Encrypt。它是完全免费的，而且它不是那种测试版的免费，它的整个目的就是永远免费。所以这太棒了，我的意思是……而且简单回顾一下，如果你不知道，我相信每个人都知道，但以防万一……你知道，当你访问一个网站时，有 HTTP 和 HTTPS。
The S stands for secure. And so what happens is under the hood, when you send some information to that website, you encrypt the information and then the website decrypts it with the help of this sort of third party to mediate all of this. And so it's not something you can just do on the server by yourself. You need to work with one of these groups to have a secure channel that is sort of authorized. And so Let's Encrypt will let you do that. So at this point now,
S 代表安全（Secure）。所以发生的事情是，在底层，当你向那个网站发送一些信息时，你加密了信息，然后网站在某种第三方中介的帮助下解密它。所以这不是你可以自己单独在服务器上完成的事情。你需要与这些组织之一合作，才能拥有一个某种程度上经过授权的安全通道。所以 Let's Encrypt 将允许你这样做。所以现在，
there's no reason not to have a secure website unless you are on Blogger. So our blog is on Blogger and Blogger custom domains don't support HTTPS. So ironically, our blog isn't on't on https and can't be which you know is okay because you're not you know logging in on our blog or giving your credit card or anything like that but in case someone comes back and says oh you know programmingthrow.com isn't the https so it's it's we can't do it i'm looking into sort of how to fix that. But at the moment, we're a little bit stuck.
没有理由不拥有一个安全的网站，除非你在使用 Blogger。所以我们的博客在 Blogger 上，而 Blogger 的自定义域名不支持 HTTPS。所以讽刺的是，我们的博客不在 HTTPS 上，而且无法实现，你知道这没关系，因为你不是在我们的博客上登录或提供信用卡信息之类的。但万一有人回来问，“哦，你知道 programmingthrow.com 不是 HTTPS 的。”所以我们做不到。我正在研究如何解决这个问题。但目前，我们有点卡住了。
We're programmers. We should write our own microservice blogging platform. Yeah, well... No, no, I'm just kidding. I looked into moving off Blogger. And as you can imagine, we have... This is episode 55. So we have a lot of content, a lot of comments. And moving all of that is not trivial.
我们是程序员。我们应该编写自己的微服务博客平台。是的，好吧……不，不，我开玩笑的。我研究过离开 Blogger。正如你可以想象的那样，我们有……这是第 55 集。所以我们有很多内容，很多评论。迁移所有这些并非易事。
Well, we heard about AI. Just make a TensorFlow to do it for us. Yeah, I need to contact Joel and have Joel give him a whiteboard interview. All right, mine is an iOS-only game. I'm sorry. I did look in advance this time. I'm prepared. It is not available on Android, and it is not free, or it hasn't't been free at least that i've seen um and it's called war bits and this is an advanced
好吧，我们听说了 AI。只要做一个 TensorFlow 来为我们做这件事就行了。是的，我需要联系 Joel，让 Joel 给他们做一个白板面试。好了，我的是一个仅限 iOS 的游戏。抱歉。这次我确实提前看了。我准备好了。它在 Android 上不可用，而且它不是免费的，或者至少我没见过它是免费的。它叫 Warbits，这是一个《高级战争》（Advance Wars）的……
wars i won't say clone because that sounds like an accusation very very similar like game so if you never played advanced wars i guess it was on game boy advance and maybe nintendo ds um yep some one of the portable nintendo consoles yeah i think there's one on 3ds as well okay it's a franchise and this i don't know exactly what you call it but you have you know people and they are on squares you have military troops and it's you attacking another set of bad guys there's just like a really fun, like a strategy game, but not like deeply strategic game. And yeah, so these games are called SRPGs. Oh.
我不会说克隆，因为那听起来像是一种指控，非常非常相似的游戏。所以如果你从未玩过《高级战争》，我想它是在 Game Boy Advance 上，也许还有任天堂 DS……是的，某种便携式任天堂游戏机。是的，我想 3DS 上也有一个。好的，这是一个系列。我不知道你到底怎么称呼它，但你有……你知道，人，他们在方格上，你有军事部队，你在攻击另一组坏人。这只是一个非常有趣、像策略游戏的东西，但不是那种深度策略游戏。是的，所以这些游戏被称为 SRPG。哦。
It comes from strategy. I think it's either strategy or squad. I don't know what the S is. But yeah, I mean, if you like Advance Wars, Final Fantasy Tactics, Fire Emblem, you know, Shining Force. If you like these games, look up SRPG in the app store and there's a decent collection. Oh, I never knew that's what they were called. So now I have these games look up srpg and in you know the app store and and there's there's a decent collection oh i never knew that's what they were called so now i have something to look up this is like final fantasy tactics as well but i feel like those games are different than this like they're more serious and there isn't really a role playing to this i mean there is like a story but i i don't know yeah i mean rpg, RPG just really means that there's upgrades.
它来自策略（Strategy）。我想要么是策略，要么是小队（Squad）。我不知道 S 是什么。但是的，我的意思是，如果你喜欢《高级战争》、《最终幻想战略版》、《火焰之纹章》，你知道，《光明力量》。如果你喜欢这些游戏，在应用商店里搜索 SRPG，有一个不错的合集。哦，我从来不知道它们叫这个名字。所以现在我有……在应用商店里搜索 SRPG，有一个不错的合集。哦，我从来不知道它们叫这个名字。所以现在我有东西可以搜索了。这就像《最终幻想战略版》一样，但我感觉这些游戏和那个不同，它们更严肃，而且这并没有真正的角色扮演。我的意思是，有一个故事，但我不知道。是的，我的意思是 RPG，RPG 真正意味着有升级。
I mean, RPG in this context really just means that there are decisions and they are permanent. But I don't remember in Advance Wars there being any real permanent decisions. Am I misremembering? I thought that you could choose a unit. It's okay. Anyways, it doesn't matter. Warbits is on iOS. If you're interested in that kind of game or you've never tried it before, you could choose a unit. It's okay. Anyways, it doesn't matter. War Bits is on iOS. If you're interested in that kind of game
我的意思是，在这种背景下，RPG 真正意味着有决策，而且它们是永久的。但我记得在《高级战争》中没有任何真正的永久决策。是我记错了吗？我以为你可以选择一个单位。没关系。总之，这不重要。Warbits 在 iOS 上。如果你对那种游戏感兴趣，或者你以前从未尝试过……
or you've never tried it before, you can check it out. There's been several others that also do it but try to kind of do it differently. And it just never kind of captured the nostalgia of Advanced Wars. So this one does a really good job because it's basically...
或者你以前从未尝试过，你可以看看它。还有其他几个也这样做，但尝试以不同的方式去做。但它从来没有捕捉到《高级战争》的那种怀旧感。所以这一个做得很好，因为它基本上……
I didn't say that. You know, like all the same basic units with the same basic traits and principles are there um and the story behind is a little wonky but you know as always it's kind of laughable to see how these people try to come up with stories to justify what is just a fun game yeah like advance wars the burn there's one called uh like burning ruin or something like that um but yeah i mean the whole premise of that was there's like a flower and if the petals all fell off the flower like humanity's lost you're like okay come on guys yeah so i think the story in this one and
我没说那个。你知道，就像所有相同的基本单位，具有相同的基本特征和原则都在那里。而且背后的故事有点古怪，但你知道，一如既往，看到这些人试图编造故事来证明这只是一个有趣的游戏是多么可笑。是的，就像《高级战争》，有一个叫……比如《燃烧的废墟》（Burning Ruin）之类的。但是的，我的意思是，它的整个前提是有一朵花，如果花瓣全部掉落，人类就完了。你会想，“好吧，拜托，伙计们。”是的，所以我认为这一个的故事……
i haven't gotten all the way through it yet is instead of fighting real world wars people have decided to fight simulations of real wars and so you're like a simulation general and okay yeah like the world has gone pacifist but they still feel like things need to be resolved using i it was it's very conflicted okay so you can check it out i'll check it out i love these type of games so i'm definitely in all right um time to talk about the thing that is going to get us lots of hate mail. Yeah, I mean, we anticipate an incredible amount of hate mail. One disclaimer is these are all things that either Patrick or I or both of us, they're all IDEs that we have used. There's a ton of IDEs that I'm sure we haven't used that. That could be great. But, you know, these are mostly one-on-one, some of the IDEs that we've experienced.
我还没完全读完它，是人们决定不再进行现实世界的战争，而是进行现实战争的模拟。所以你就像一个模拟将军。好吧，是的，就像世界已经变得和平主义了，但他们仍然觉得事情需要通过……我……这非常矛盾。好吧，你可以看看它。我会看看的，我喜欢这类游戏，所以我绝对会加入。好了，是时候谈谈那个会让我们收到大量仇恨邮件的事情了。是的，我的意思是，我们预料到会有大量的仇恨邮件。一个免责声明是，这些都是 Patrick 或我，或者我们俩都使用过的 IDE。肯定有很多我们没用过的 IDE，它们可能很棒。但你知道，这些主要是我们体验过的一些 IDE。
And we've gone through a lot. We're not married to a particular IDE, either of us. And so I think that that's nice because together we have pretty good coverage on almost all the popular IDEs. So I actually don't know that we'll get a ton of flame when we're talking about editors because I don't intend to state anything absolute. Well, maybe a couple of things. But instead, I want to talk a little bit about like editor philosophy.
我们经历了很多。我们俩都没有对某个特定的 IDE 情有独钟。所以我认为这很好，因为加在一起，我们对几乎所有流行的 IDE 都有很好的覆盖。所以我其实不知道我们在谈论编辑器时会受到多少抨击，因为我不打算陈述任何绝对的东西。好吧，也许一两件事。但相反，我想谈谈编辑器的哲学。
So I think one of the things that, to be productive as a programmer, the editor you choose should have like some common traits. One is that there should be some level of customization to it. That is that there should be some level of customization to it. That is that things can be shifted into a way that you like it. And there's a balance here where you'll hear people argue about, if I make it so customized that when I go to someone else's computer, I can't get things done. And ultimately you spend most of the time programming at your
所以我认为，作为一名程序员要提高效率，你选择的编辑器应该具备一些共同的特征。一是应该有一定程度的定制性。也就是说，事情可以调整成你喜欢的样子。这里有一个平衡，你会听到人们争论，如果我把它定制得太厉害，当我用别人的电脑时，我就没法工作了。但最终你大部分时间是在你的……
computer. So I feel like it's worth making it customized to you, but maybe not so much crazy customization that you're doing customization just for customization sake. And that's probably a hard balance to strike, but don't go so far where you're spending more time updating and tweaking stuff than actually like doing your work.
电脑上编程。所以我认为值得为你自己进行定制，但也许不要进行那种为了定制而定制的疯狂定制。这可能是一个很难把握的平衡，但不要走得太远，以至于你花在更新和调整东西上的时间比实际工作的时间还多。
Like that's probably too much. Yeah, definitely. I usually, you know, once maybe every year or so i just say okay i'm gonna take some time to like improve my workflow and improve my editor and things like that but yeah you shouldn't there shouldn't be something that you just do every week or every day that'd be and some people do some people are like i will spend however much time necessary to create a way to shave off one extra keystroke in Vim or VI. Okay, sure. I mean, if that makes you happy, I'm not going to tell you you're wrong.
那可能就太多了。是的，绝对。我通常，你知道，可能每年左右，我就会说，“好吧，我要花点时间来改进我的工作流程和编辑器之类的。”但是的，你不应该……不应该有那种你每周或每天都在做的事情。有些人会这样做，有些人会说，“我会花必要的时间来创造一种方法，在 Vim 或 VI 中节省一个额外的按键。”好吧，当然。我的意思是，如果这让你快乐，我不会告诉你你错了。
That's not the way I tend to operate. Yeah. The other thing I think when you're choosing an editor that you should think about is the searchability. And I mean a couple of things by this, but just as the ability to find things in the code, especially when you're in code that you don't work in a lot or is new to you and i think this is really important and this will separate out in my opinion um what makes some things not so good choices for people um and the other thing i mean about searchability is specifically and i and i thought of this the other day when i was someone was talking about how they switched to
那不是我倾向于操作的方式。是的。我认为在选择编辑器时你应该考虑的另一件事是可搜索性。我的意思是这包含几层含义，但仅仅是能够在代码中找到东西的能力，特别是当你处于你不常工作或对你来说是新的代码中时。我认为这非常重要，在我看来，这将区分出什么对人们来说不是好的选择。我指的可搜索性的另一件事是……我前几天想到这个，当有人在谈论他们如何切换到……
using vi because they thought it was so much better. And in reality, like I kind of asked them a couple of questions and it seemed like they were switching more to VI because they wanted to be able to say that they use VI, which OK, that's fine. But they weren't very efficient in it and they weren't pursuing a way to be efficient. And the thing I kind of use as at least for me, one measure of how efficient you're being in your code is how long it takes when you're looking at a piece of code you've never looked at before and you come to a
使用 VI，因为他们认为它好得多。实际上，我问了他们几个问题，看起来他们切换到 VI 更多是因为他们想说他们使用 VI，好吧，这没问题。但他们在其中效率不高，而且他们没有追求提高效率的方法。对我来说，衡量你在代码中效率如何的一个标准是，当你查看一段你从未看过的代码，并且你遇到了……
usage of a class and you don't know what that class does and some meth or a method it doesn't matter some methods being called a function how long does it take you to go from that function in that file to where that function is defined. So what learning about what that function does, reading about the comments, all of that stuff. And I think you want to work to minimize that. So in some cases, your tool may or may not provide that out of the box. So some of the things we're going to talk about, like the IDEs, and we're going to talk about integrated here means in a minute, but they let you do that very easily easily like it might be a right click and a go to definition or an you know a button like an f3 that when you're on top of something it takes
一个类的用法，而你不知道那个类做什么，或者一个方法……没关系，某个方法正在被调用，一个函数，从那个文件中的那个函数到那个函数定义的地方需要多长时间？所以，了解那个函数做什么，阅读注释，所有这些东西。我认为你想要努力最小化这个时间。所以在某些情况下，你的工具可能会也可能不会开箱即用地提供这一点。所以我们要谈论的一些东西，比如 IDE，我们稍后会谈论集成，但它们让你非常容易地做到这一点。比如可能是右键点击并“转到定义”，或者是一个按钮，比如 F3，当你停在某个东西上时，它会带……
you to the place in the code so it has understanding about your code but that isn't to say you have to use one of the integrated things you could there are ways to do this in vi and maybe we can talk about that like c tags or whatever but for me the way i'll if you not that i'll i try not to be a mean person but if you come to me and tell me like oh my solution for editor is better because vi is really awesome and i'm gonna want to know like oh how do you have it set up and i've seen people with incredible um stacks of stuff that their tools and configuration and um intuitiveness of the code where they really can bounce back and forth. And I've seen other people that when you ask them to handle this problem I've just described,
你到代码中的那个位置，所以它对你的代码有理解。但这并不是说你必须使用集成的东西之一。在 VI 中有方法可以做到这一点，也许我们可以谈谈，比如 ctags 之类的。但对我来说，如果……不是说我想做一个刻薄的人，但如果你来告诉我，“哦，我的编辑器解决方案更好，因为 VI 真的很棒。”我会想知道，“哦，你是怎么设置的？”我见过人们拥有令人难以置信的工具和配置堆栈，以及代码的直观性，他们确实可以来回跳转。我也见过其他人，当你要求他们处理我刚才描述的这个问题时，
you know, they go to another window, they open the shell, they grep through a bunch of files, and they're trying to like manually inspect each line looking for which one is most likely to be the one where it's defined. And to me, that's just, it takes you out of the one where it's defined and to me that's just it takes you out of the context it's too slow it doesn't work for me and and i think if you are doing that you should either seek to find a way to improve that or switch to another solution that might be better for you don't just do something because it's wearing the hair shirt is what i've heard it called for some programming languages where people used to wear a shirt made out of some animal hair that is like really itchy to remind them about like the fact that they're going through this
你知道，他们去另一个窗口，打开 shell，grep 一堆文件，他们试图手动检查每一行，寻找哪一行最可能是定义它的地方。对我来说，这太……它让你脱离了上下文，太慢了，对我来说行不通。而且我认为如果你在这样做，你应该寻求一种方法来改进它，或者切换到另一个可能更适合你的解决方案。不要仅仅因为它是“穿毛衣”（hair shirt）——这是我听说过的一些编程语言的说法，人们过去常穿一件由某种动物毛发制成的衬衫，非常痒，用来提醒他们正在经历这种……
punishment um and so some people do that like i'm a good programmer because i do things the hard way but uh i don't know yeah that's not that's that's never true well i mean. That's not for me. Yeah, I agree. I think that you have to be able to, you know, I mean, editors are made to edit files, but code is really not about files. It's really about this web of functions. And, like, how those functions are mapped to files, like, it depends on the programming language, but it could even be just arbitrary. And so like an editor that, you know, if you have Vim or Emacs or, you know, one of these editors,
惩罚。所以有些人这样做，比如“我是一个好程序员，因为我用困难的方式做事。”但……我不知道。是的，那从来都不是真的。好吧，我的意思是。那不适合我。是的，我同意。我认为你必须能够，你知道，我的意思是，编辑器是用来编辑文件的，但代码其实不是关于文件的。它实际上是关于这个函数网。而且，这些函数是如何映射到文件的，这取决于编程语言，但它甚至可以是任意的。所以像一个编辑器，你知道，如果你有 Vim 或 Emacs，或者这些编辑器之一，
and you only can look at one file at a time, then you're not really doing it right. Yeah, and yeah, there's many ways to solve this problem. And i think asserting that your way is the best way is also just not cool you're not helping um i think different people think differently some people think it's great to sit in front of a keyboard or to say that i can use a computer from 40 years ago that doesn't have the cursor key okay great sure whatever but the chance of me running across that in like my day-to-day is just really low and i think it's also very good to try stuff occasionally to see if you like something better and to see if hey maybe i do
而你一次只能看一个文件，那么你并没有真正做对。是的，解决这个问题的方法有很多。而且我认为断言你的方式是最好的方式也是不酷的，你没有在帮忙。我认为不同的人有不同的思考方式。有些人认为坐在键盘前，或者说“我可以使用 40 年前的电脑，它没有光标键”很棒。好吧，太棒了，随你便。但我遇到这种情况的几率在我的日常生活中真的很低。而且我认为偶尔尝试一下新东西看看你是否喜欢更好的东西，看看“嘿，也许我确实……
fit in with the way this thing works and instead of all editors needing to be usable by everyone i think some of them have realized they just should be used by some people and that they'll just cater to those people and i think that's perfectly fine and i agree jason we are calling this editor wars but really talking about editing in the context of not writing a novel but like editing code so working in a code base you know a git repository like those kinds of things all together and i think that there are some solutions which you'll hear ide integrated development environment or what i'll call like a stack or roll your own where an integrated development environment you typically have an editor where you can edit code some notion of a project explorer or file explorer, where you can
适合这种东西的工作方式”也是非常好的。与其让所有编辑器都需要被每个人使用，我认为其中一些已经意识到它们应该只被某些人使用，并且它们只会迎合那些人，我认为这完全没问题。我同意，Jason，我们称之为编辑器战争，但实际上是在谈论编辑，不是写小说，而是编辑代码。所以在一个代码库中工作，比如一个 git 仓库，所有这些东西加在一起。我认为有一些解决方案，你会听到 IDE（集成开发环境），或者我称之为“堆栈”或“自己动手”（roll your own）。在集成开发环境中，你通常有一个可以编辑代码的编辑器，某种项目资源管理器或文件资源管理器的概念，你可以……
kind of go to the different files that you have, or classes in your code, some way to navigate, and then often has a way to invoke the compiler, or even the compilers kind of built into the IDE. And all of that is done kind of within one executable that you launched once and kind of had that as a default configuration. A roll your own would be more something, we'll talk about in a minute, other solutions where it primarily is just editing of a single file,
去你拥有的不同文件，或者代码中的类，某种导航方式，然后通常有一种调用编译器的方法，甚至编译器是内置在 IDE 中的。所有这些都是在一个你启动一次的可执行文件中完成的，并将其作为默认配置。自己动手会更多是某种……我们稍后会谈论其他解决方案，其中它主要只是编辑单个文件，
but then there may be ways for you to choose plugins or other applications or use, you know, something within Windows or Linux to kind of customize your window to have other features as well. And then, to kind of customize your window to have other features as well. And then you've kind of created a set of linking and plugins and, or found them on the internet ways and shortcuts to go between the different programs that are together helping you do your code programming, debugging, compiling loop, pushing all of that
但然后可能有方法让你选择插件或其他应用程序，或者使用，你知道，Windows 或 Linux 中的某些东西来定制你的窗口以拥有其他功能。然后，你创建了一套链接和插件，或者在互联网上找到了方法和快捷键，在帮助你进行代码编程、调试、编译循环、推送所有这些东西的不同程序之间跳转……
stuff. Yep, I think those are kind of the two approaches that i've seen yeah definitely um so just to knock a couple of things out uh the simplest like ide is just a text editor i mean a pure text editor so this is like pico or nano on unix or just notepad or wordpad on on windows and these things don't really know anything about code they don't do any highlighting or anything you can only look at one file at a time but um if you're really kind of desperate like there's um there's you know notepad on every windows machine you're guaranteed it's going to be there um and uh you know you can you can write anything in them but
东西。是的，我认为这是我见过的两种方法。是的，绝对。所以，只是为了敲定几件事。最简单的 IDE 只是一个文本编辑器。我的意思是纯文本编辑器。所以这就像 Unix 上的 pico 或 nano，或者 Windows 上的记事本或写字板。这些东西对代码一无所知，它们不做任何高亮显示之类的。你一次只能看一个文件。但……如果你真的很绝望，比如……你知道，每台 Windows 机器上都有记事本，你保证它会在那里。而且……你知道，你可以在里面写任何东西，但……
we don't record yeah i mean i think the thing that this fails is there isn't really customization options for the most part like you can't say that's right it won't do things like when i go to the next line you know automatically indent that line based on what i type like if i typed a brace it needs to indent over if i didn't it needs to stay at the same spot. You know, it doesn't necessarily understand like tab and shift tab for like getting rid of indentation. It just doesn't have those notions. So it isn't efficient for editing code
我们不记录。是的，我的意思是，我认为它失败的地方在于，在大多数情况下没有真正的定制选项。比如你不能说……没错，它不会做一些事情，比如当我转到下一行时，你知道，根据我输入的内容自动缩进那一行。比如如果我输入了一个大括号，它需要缩进；如果我没有，它需要保持在同一个位置。你知道，它不一定理解 Tab 和 Shift+Tab 来消除缩进。它只是没有这些概念。所以它对于编辑代码来说效率不高，
and isn't really customizable. So as Jason said, last resort, you should pretty much, if you're using these, you should really look for something else. Yep. And then there's what I call like IDE as a platform and so this is where as patrick mentioned you're going to have to do like a pretty decent amount of heavy lifting to get this where you want um and so this is you know where the emacs the vi and the vim um editors belong um and and uh
而且也不是真正可定制的。所以正如 Jason 所说，最后的手段，你应该……如果你在使用这些，你应该真的寻找其他东西。是的。然后就是我所说的“作为平台的 IDE”。所以这就是 Patrick 提到的地方，你将不得不做相当多的繁重工作才能达到你想要的效果。所以这就是 Emacs、VI 和 Vim 编辑器所属的地方。而且……
you know you could argue sublime and adam are are here as well but we'll talk about them later because they're more sort of futuristic. So I don't think these are ideas of platform I would refer to these more as like keyboard focused so both Emacs and VI for me that the big thing they share in common is saying that you should be able to do everything from your keyboard without having to lift up and go to the mouse um well so so i've i've only ever well i take it back i've used cursors curses emacs before but uh i'm definitely like a heavy mouse user and i still use emacs yeah i think the big thing about this is um it supports kind of everything like for example when typescript came out um there was syntax highlighting you know when the language came out there was a emacs module like the developers of typescript released an emacs module and so um i guess typescript is a microsoft thing so visual
你知道，你可以争论 Sublime 和 Atom 也是这里，但我们稍后会谈论它们，因为它们更具未来感。所以我不认为这些是“作为平台的 IDE”，我会更多地将它们称为“键盘聚焦”。所以 Emacs 和 VI 对我来说，它们共同的最大特点是说你应该能够从键盘上完成所有事情，而不必抬起手去用鼠标。好吧，所以我……我只用过……我收回前言，我用过 curses Emacs，但……我绝对是一个重度鼠标用户，我仍然使用 Emacs。是的，我认为关于这个的最大特点是……它支持几乎所有东西。例如，当 TypeScript 出来时……有语法高亮。你知道，当语言出来时，有一个 Emacs 模块。所以 TypeScript 的开发者发布了一个 Emacs 模块。所以……我猜 TypeScript 是微软的东西，所以 Visual
studio would work but but uh you know the thing about emacs is that it can edit almost any file and and and has syntax highlighting for almost every language um and because it's so extensible and also because the bare bones emacs is so poor oh you are going to start getting lame well no i mean i love emacs but i'll be the first person to say that default Emacs kind of makes my eyes hurt. But there's so many modules and so much support that you can do everything in Emacs well. I don't believe the same is true for outside of Emacs and Vim. If you want to do Eclipse, but the project is a node.js pro well
Studio 会工作，但……你知道，Emacs 的特点是它可以编辑几乎任何文件，并且对几乎每种语言都有语法高亮。而且因为它非常可扩展，而且因为裸机 Emacs 非常简陋……哦，你要开始被抨击了。好吧，不，我的意思是，我喜欢 Emacs，但我会第一个说默认的 Emacs 确实让我的眼睛很痛。但有太多的模块和太多的支持，你可以把 Emacs 里的所有事情都做好。我不认为在 Emacs 和 Vim 之外也是如此。如果你想用 Eclipse，但项目是一个 Node.js 项目……好吧，
eclipse actually is getting there um but you know like let's take like intellij or something and the project is node.js you're kind of hosed um and so i feel as if like as a developer you have to make one of two choices you either have to say i'm going to do almost everything in emacs um or you have to you know generate sort of this ensemble of of editors like maybe eclipse for most things but then if you have c++ you have to use you know uh like visual studio or something but i mean i think a hybrid approach is actually reasonable and you can't use it somewhat and a lot of people and a lot of people a lot of people don't i think it's i'm pretty sure it's true for both but in eclipse you can have it support both emacs and vi style uh text editing and so you can drop it into a so it handles normal behavior by default but then there's a way to
Eclipse 其实正在赶上……但你知道，比如让我们拿 IntelliJ 之类的，而项目是 Node.js，你有点被困住了。所以我感觉作为一名开发者，你必须做出两个选择之一。你要么说“我几乎要在 Emacs 中做所有事情”，要么你必须……生成这种编辑器集合。比如大多数事情用 Eclipse，但如果你有 C++，你必须使用……比如 Visual Studio 之类的。但我的意思是，我认为混合方法实际上是合理的，你可以适度使用它。而且很多人……很多人……很多人不……我认为这对两者都适用，但在 Eclipse 中，你可以让它同时支持 Emacs 和 VI 风格的文本编辑。所以你可以把它放入一个……它默认处理正常行为，但有一种方法可以……
basically tell it to emulate as if you were in an emacs or vi window for just your text editing place and i feel actually we should mention that. So people might not be familiar with this, but if you're editing a doc in Microsoft Word or something, you would select a block of text with the mouse and then you'd click the B to make it bold. And there's keyboard shortcuts like Control-B and things like that.
基本上告诉它模拟你好像在一个 Emacs 或 VI 窗口中，只针对你的文本编辑位置。而且我感觉我们确实应该提到这一点。所以人们可能不熟悉这一点，但如果你在 Microsoft Word 或其他软件中编辑文档，你会用鼠标选择一块文本，然后点击 B 使其加粗。而且有键盘快捷键，比如 Control-B 之类的。
But it're designed, it's designed around the mouse. Like using Microsoft Word without a mouse would be super painful. But these editors like Emacs and Vim, as Patrick said, they're designed to work without a mouse. And so if you want to go to, you know, line 1000 in Emacs, you would do escape GG 1000, and that sounds kind of painful to have to remember that when you could just scroll with the mouse wheel, but it actually saves a pretty decent amount of time, and some of the keyboard strokes are actually quite worth it to kind of memorize.
但它是围绕鼠标设计的。比如不用鼠标使用 Microsoft Word 会非常痛苦。但正如 Patrick 所说，像 Emacs 和 Vim 这样的编辑器，它们被设计为无需鼠标即可工作。所以如果你想在 Emacs 中跳转到第 1000 行，你会输入 escape GG 1000，虽然记住这些操作听起来有点痛苦，毕竟你可以直接用鼠标滚轮滚动，但它实际上节省了相当多的时间，而且有些快捷键确实值得记忆。
So the catch with that is if you're used to, you know, escape GG, and that's your muscle memory has just attuned to that, then you go to Eclipse, you're just going to end up typing Gs all over the place. Like this happened to me in the beginning. Like I'd just be editing a file, and all of a sudden I'd type two Gs, and it's because I wanted to go to a line. And so, so you can actually customize most editors that we'll talk about, let you support, um, Emacs keys.
所以这里的问题是，如果你习惯了 escape GG，并且你的肌肉记忆已经适应了这一点，那么当你转到 Eclipse 时，你最终会到处输入 G。比如我刚开始时就发生过这种情况。我正在编辑一个文件，突然输入了两个 G，那是因为我想跳转到某一行。所以，我们稍后会讨论的大多数编辑器其实都可以自定义，让你支持 Emacs 的按键。
I think that's the biggest difference about like Emacs and VI is they allow you, and I'm not going to get into which is better or worse. I tend to use VI, I just never gotten into Emacs. So when I use VI or use one of these, I use i use vi um but i think that they allow you to have different ways of operating so like jason said you can go to a specific line when i used eclipse initially like i just never had a desire to go to a specific line that wasn't the way i operated um because it doesn't really support it natively or you know i was reading some interesting stuff about vi where people were saying you know one of the good things about not using the cursor keys and forcing you to using hjkl for cursor navigation um is that it gets you into a different way of thinking and then it allows you to for instance start getting used to as you're saying like going to relative line numbers or going to
我认为这是 Emacs 和 VI 之间最大的区别，它们允许你——我不会讨论哪个更好或更差。我倾向于使用 VI，我从来没有深入使用过 Emacs。所以当我使用 VI 或其中之一时，我使用 VI，但我认为它们允许你有不同的操作方式。就像 Jason 说的，你可以跳转到特定的行。我最初使用 Eclipse 时，从来没有跳转到特定行的需求，那不是我的操作方式，因为它本身并不真正支持这一点。或者，你知道，我读到了一些关于 VI 的有趣内容，人们说不使用光标键并强制你使用 hjkl 进行光标导航的好处之一，是它让你进入了一种不同的思维方式，然后它允许你，例如，开始习惯于你所说的跳转到相对行号或
relative places within your code and so your navigation becomes more intuitive about jumping whole lines instead of you know single lines at a time or or whatever jumping sets of lines or repeating actions a number of time instead of manually doing it every time so reducing the number of keystrokes needed and emacs and vi are very powerful both out of the box and with the level of customization of everything that they allow you to do in helping you reduce your keystroke count and some of that requires you shifting your mindset for good or bad yeah it definitely is a learning curve no doubt um but i feel this way about you know coding and about email is you know i spend hours every day doing doing either of those and so if i could shave off 10 it's significant yeah
代码中的相对位置，这样你的导航就会变得更加直观，比如跳转整行而不是一次一行，或者跳转一组行，或者重复操作多次，而不是每次都手动执行。这减少了所需的按键次数。Emacs 和 VI 在开箱即用以及允许你进行各种自定义以帮助你减少按键次数方面都非常强大。其中一些确实需要你转变思维方式，无论好坏。是的，这绝对有一个学习曲线，毫无疑问。但我对编程和电子邮件也有这种感觉，我每天都要花几个小时做这两件事，所以如果我能节省 10% 的时间，那意义重大。
i you know um it's hard it depends on me sometimes i'm cranking out code and i'd agree with you but there's a lot of other times where the limiting factor for me isn't how fast my fingers can push the code into the editor right like i'm limited i tend to and it's just the nature of the work i do i tend to need to actually think about the stuff i'm writing and tend to and it's just the nature of the work i do i tend to need to actually think about the stuff i'm writing and so it takes a little longer for each line to come out for me and so in that regime the editor doesn't get in my way not normally right yeah no definitely i don't think typing faster is really helping anybody but no it does because there's sometimes you just really want to bang out like boilerplate code or whatever and you just type type type type you know as fast as you can go
你知道，这很难说，有时我正在快速编写代码，我同意你的观点，但还有很多时候，限制我的因素并不是我的手指将代码推入编辑器的速度。我倾向于——这只是我工作性质使然——我倾向于需要真正思考我正在写的东西，所以对我来说，每一行代码的产出都需要更长一点的时间，在这种情况下，编辑器通常不会妨碍我。是的，绝对，我不认为打字更快真的能帮到任何人。但确实有帮助，因为有时你真的想快速敲出样板代码之类的东西，你就会尽可能快地打字。
oh yeah emacs has this like uh boilerplate thing where you can hit f3 we're not going to play this game because you can say emacs or vi has insert like just literally solution to any problem you want to make your coffee from within emacs great there's a plugin for that sure yeah i got it but um we'll do that the whole time yeah that's a fair point um anyway so so there's there's emacs vi and then um when java came out the thing about java is um java had a gui like had ui libraries that shipped with the language so in other words anyone who is programming in java could make like a window on the screen and draw like menus and things like that which had never really been done before it used to be you know sure you have c++ but you
哦，是的，Emacs 有这种样板功能，你可以按 F3。我们不会玩这个游戏，因为你可以说 Emacs 或 VI 有插入功能，简直是解决任何问题的方案，你想在 Emacs 里煮咖啡？太棒了，有插件可以做到。当然，我明白了。但我们会一直这样做。是的，这是一个合理的观点。总之，有 Emacs 和 VI，然后当 Java 出来时，Java 的特点是它有一个 GUI，即随语言提供的 UI 库。换句话说，任何使用 Java 编程的人都可以像在屏幕上创建一个窗口并绘制菜单之类的东西，这在以前从未真正实现过。以前，当然你有 C++，但你
know you need to download a bunch of libraries i don't know that it had never been done before because i think some of the other more obscure languages had done it before but it was kind of like oh yeah there's like first widespread tk and widespread yeah sure that's fair that's fair so um so what happened is a lot of people at that time there's sort of this explosion of developer visual developer tools and then's are obviously one of those and so there's netbeans eclipse and intellij which are all java-based ide's and i you know i used to use netbeans there was a time where eclipse was very slow and crashed all the time, like early days of Eclipse. But as soon as Eclipse became stable, I switched to Eclipse.
需要下载一堆库。我不知道这是否是“从未实现过”，因为我认为一些其他更晦涩的语言以前也做过，但它就像是“哦，是的，这是第一个广泛使用的 TK”。是的，当然，这很公平。所以，当时发生了很多开发者视觉开发工具的爆发，NetBeans、Eclipse 和 IntelliJ 显然都是基于 Java 的 IDE。我以前用过 NetBeans，有一段时间 Eclipse 非常慢而且总是崩溃，那是 Eclipse 的早期阶段。但一旦 Eclipse 变得稳定，我就转用了 Eclipse。
And I've never used IntelliJ. I haven't. I was going to say that JetBrains is like the people, and we talked about them a while ago, having to kerfuffle with changing how they were charging people. I've just never used it i know a lot of people though who really say it is it doesn't matter how much money you want to charge like this is totally worth it um but no i've mostly used eclipse for for my java yeah i've also used eclipse and eclipse actually is starting to get emacs status where um if you're a programming language inventor and you don't support eclipse through some plugin or something you you um are kind of doing yourself a disservice and so so
我从没用过 IntelliJ。我没用过。我本来想说 JetBrains 是那些人，我们前段时间谈论过他们，因为改变收费方式而引起了骚动。我只是从没用过它，但我认识很多人，他们真的说无论你想收多少钱，这都完全值得。但我大部分时间还是用 Eclipse 来写 Java。是的，我也用过 Eclipse，而且 Eclipse 实际上开始达到 Emacs 的地位，如果你是一位编程语言发明家，而你不通过某种插件支持 Eclipse，你就是在给自己找麻烦。所以
you're starting to see a lot more support now um for you know everything from you know typescript to groovy to you know scala um they just are providing these sort of uh it's actually cool in scala you can actually click on a button in the website that launches something in eclipse that installs the scala plugin like i don't know exactly what's good yeah it does sound like a security hole doesn't it i don't know exactly what's going on there but um it's basically like a one-click thing from the scala website which is pretty cool um i don't know exactly what's going on there but um it's basically like a one click thing from the scala website which is pretty cool um i don't know i'm just i'm just harassing you same as when you go from itunes yeah so um so it's legit but but the uh uh so yeah i'm actually
你现在开始看到更多的支持了，从 TypeScript 到 Groovy 再到 Scala，他们只是提供了这些……实际上在 Scala 中很酷，你可以点击网站上的一个按钮，它会在 Eclipse 中启动并安装 Scala 插件。我不知道这到底有什么好。是的，这听起来确实像个安全漏洞，不是吗？我不知道那里到底发生了什么，但它基本上就像 Scala 网站上的“一键式”操作，这很酷。我不知道，我只是在骚扰你，就像你从 iTunes 那里一样。所以，它是合法的，但……所以是的，我实际上
starting to use eclipse more and i might um you know completely switch from emacs to eclipse because eclipse is that was my big fear with all of these is that you know if it didn't support a language i would have to use emacs anyways and but now eclipse is getting to the point where it supports and it is true that like you should never believe you're going to just stay in a single application i mean even in eclipse you might have to drop into something else to manage your project i mean you can open the project file but there may be a better way of managing your project or handling git like for instance a lot there are git plugins for eclipse but i never use them i always just drop back to the command line to do it that's just because how i wanted to do it um and so i think a
开始更多地使用 Eclipse，我可能会完全从 Emacs 切换到 Eclipse，因为 Eclipse 是……这就是我担心所有这些的原因，如果它不支持某种语言，我无论如何都得用 Emacs。但现在 Eclipse 已经发展到支持的地步了。而且确实，你不应该相信你会一直待在一个单一的应用程序中。即使在 Eclipse 中，你可能也需要切换到其他工具来管理你的项目。我的意思是，你可以打开项目文件，但可能有更好的方法来管理你的项目或处理 Git。例如，Eclipse 有很多 Git 插件，但我从不使用它们，我总是回到命令行来做，那只是因为我想要那样做。所以我认为
hybrid approach is still reasonable um for all of these where you you know still need some sort of stack or roll your own whatever you call it the set of tools you're going to use but the other thing is so far i think all the ones we've talked about have been cross-platform except for like notepad which is only on windows um but emacs vi netbeans eclipse intellij or i know at least eclipse and intellij i think are cross-platform so osx linux windows yep yeah okay that means as well but all of these will run on you know kind of any platform you are but i'll i will say one of the caveats is things like vi and emacs you it takes a little longer when you're on like windows uh and osx isn't too bad with like
混合方法对于所有这些仍然是合理的，你仍然需要某种堆栈或自己动手，无论你怎么称呼它，即你将要使用的一套工具。但另一件事是，到目前为止，我认为我们谈论的所有工具都是跨平台的，除了像 Notepad 只能在 Windows 上运行。但 Emacs、VI、NetBeans、Eclipse、IntelliJ，或者我知道至少 Eclipse 和 IntelliJ 是跨平台的，所以 OSX、Linux、Windows 都有。是的，好的，这意味着它们可以在任何平台上运行。但我会说一个警告是，像 VI 和 Emacs 这样的东西，当你在 Windows 上时需要更长的时间。OSX 还好，有像
something like homebrew or i guess it used to be mac ports was the way you used to do it but getting the normal linux tools. But they kind of assume, and people, if you look for help in VIR emacs, are going to kind of assume you're on a OSX or Linux system. And they're going to suggest you to use tools that are specific to those systems. And then whether or not they're available on Windows just depends.
Homebrew 之类的东西，或者我想以前 Mac Ports 是你使用的方式，但获取正常的 Linux 工具。但它们有点假设，如果你在 VI 或 Emacs 中寻求帮助，人们会假设你在 OSX 或 Linux 系统上。他们会建议你使用特定于这些系统的工具。至于它们在 Windows 上是否可用，那就看情况了。
Yeah, that's right. So yeah, there's a section, i made a section called corporate ids and so these are not cross platform yeah that's right these are your you know visual studio and your xcode um i've used xcode a decent amount um xcode's okay um i dislike xcode but visual studio the last time I used it, had gotten a lot better than when I had first used it, and I've heard it's gotten even better, so I feel comfortable saying Visual Studio's probably pretty good now.
是的，没错。所以，我做了一个名为“企业级 IDE”的部分，这些不是跨平台的。是的，没错，这些是你的 Visual Studio 和 Xcode。我用过相当多的 Xcode，Xcode 还行，我不喜欢 Xcode。但 Visual Studio 我上次使用时，比我刚开始用的时候好多了，而且我听说它变得更好了，所以我可以放心地说 Visual Studio 现在可能相当不错了。
Yeah, I mean, Xcode fails the, you know, I want it to support many things test. You know, in other words, like, if I'm in Xcode... You're making an OSX application or an iOS or something within the Apple ecosystem. Sure, sure. But even that notwithstanding, if I'm doing that, you know, I'm writing this application and I write a JSON file. Now I want to open that JSON file in something that feels good, where it actually does folding of the JSON structure and things like that.
是的，我的意思是，Xcode 在“我希望它支持很多东西”的测试中失败了。换句话说，如果我在 Xcode 中……你在 Apple 生态系统中制作 OSX 应用程序或 iOS 应用程序。当然，当然。但即使如此，如果我正在做那个，我正在编写这个应用程序，我写了一个 JSON 文件。现在我想在一个感觉不错的东西中打开那个 JSON 文件，它实际上可以折叠 JSON 结构之类的东西。
I'm pretty sure Xcode will just open it in a text file. And I mean, I'm not 100% sure, but I'm like about JSON specifically, but I've had this issue with both of these, Visual Studio and Xcode, where there's going to be some file it doesn't understand. And because the plugin support isn't there, it's going to be you know some file it doesn't understand and because the plugin support isn't there it's going to be just a pure text file and i'm going to have to switch to eclipse or emacs
我很确定 Xcode 只会把它当作一个文本文件打开。我的意思是，我不 100% 确定，特别是关于 JSON，但我在这两者（Visual Studio 和 Xcode）上都遇到过这个问题，有些文件它不理解。而且因为没有插件支持，它只会是一个纯文本文件，我将不得不切换到 Eclipse 或 Emacs
or one of these other things um you know if i want it's really something going to understand the file yeah also i think some of these have different levels of integration like visual studio is mostly geared towards its own way of describing a project and Xcode similarly, you need to have an Xcode description of the project, at least as far as I know. But things like Eclipse too, depending on what project management your team is using, it has support for most of the big ones, but it's not as bad because it isn't assuming
或其他东西。如果你想要它真正理解这个文件。是的，我也认为其中一些有不同程度的集成。Visual Studio 主要针对它自己描述项目的方式，Xcode 也类似，你需要有一个 Xcode 的项目描述，至少据我所知是这样。但像 Eclipse 这样，取决于你的团队正在使用什么项目管理，它支持大多数主流工具，但它没那么糟糕，因为它没有假设
that it's a very specific project description. Yeah, I mean, if you're doing your development correctly in in Eclipse you should be able to just throw away the project file and it should just be able to just be regenerated so if you're using like maven gradle CMake or any of these systems you can just auto generate the Eclipse kind of project whenever but you're right for the other ones i mean cmake can technically do xcode and visual studio but um it's not as good like you'll typically have to make changes to the project file so there are some new editors that are making inroads for people liking the first one is sublime which is written as far as i know by like a single guy and it came out a few years
它是一个非常具体的项目描述。是的，我的意思是，如果你在 Eclipse 中正确地进行开发，你应该能够直接丢弃项目文件，它应该能够被重新生成。所以如果你使用像 Maven、Gradle、CMake 或任何这些系统，你可以随时自动生成 Eclipse 项目。但你是对的，对于其他的，我的意思是 CMake 技术上可以做 Xcode 和 Visual Studio，但它没那么好，你通常必须对项目文件进行更改。所以有一些新的编辑器正在为人们所喜爱，第一个是 Sublime，据我所知是由一个人编写的，它在几年前出现。
ago i guess we should have looked it up but um it's a free to try and it gives you a warning um if you don't buy it so you're supposed to buy it after some amount of time um and the nice thing about sublime is it has a pretty good ecosystem around it for plugins and understanding code natively um but it doesn't try to integrate really as far as i can tell with any sort of like project understanding so you can point out a folder and it'll see a folder structure on disk, but doesn't try to kind of integrate with your project structure and allow you to like add new files to your project, you know, kind of in an intuitive way.
我想我们应该查一下，但它是免费试用的，如果你不买它会给你一个警告，所以你在一段时间后应该购买它。Sublime 的好处是它周围有一个相当不错的插件生态系统，并且可以原生理解代码。但据我所知，它并没有试图与任何类型的项目理解集成。所以你可以指向一个文件夹，它会看到磁盘上的文件夹结构，但它不会试图与你的项目结构集成，也不会让你以直观的方式向项目中添加新文件。
But it has a nice like overview on the right side where it shows like your code, but like shrunken down because it turns out you can recognize what the code structure, where you are in the file just just by having looked at it. I didn't really think about it before, but when I saw that and I used it, I was like, oh, that's really cool. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. One sad thing about Sublime, I just looked it up,
但它在右侧有一个很好的概览，显示了你的代码，但缩小了，因为事实证明，你只需看一眼就能识别出代码结构以及你在文件中的位置。我以前没怎么想过，但当我看到它并使用它时，我想，哦，那真的很酷。是的，是的，这很有道理。关于 Sublime 的一件可悲的事情是，我刚查了一下，
it's not open source. It's paid and it's written by, yeah, it's like a company, right? So it's not open source. Yeah, I mean mean that's actually the exception uh well maybe we should have put it in the corporate ids but but all of the java ones we mentioned eclipse and that means intellij emacs vim are all open source and uh um you know i mean are you really going to be hacking on eclipse on emacs probably not but the fact that it's open source means that if
它不是开源的。它是付费的，由一家公司编写，对吧？所以它不是开源的。是的，我的意思是那实际上是个例外。好吧，也许我们应该把它放在企业级 IDE 里。但我们提到的所有 Java 工具，Eclipse、NetBeans、IntelliJ、Emacs、Vim 都是开源的。而且，我的意思是，你真的会去修改 Eclipse 或 Emacs 吗？可能不会，但它是开源的事实意味着如果
you know some new language takes over and it just becomes super popular like it's kind of happening now with um um with react where it's this uh jsx file that has like html and stuff embedded in it like if something like that happens and really starts to take off and you join a company they said okay you have to write these jsx files um you know sublime without sublime no but the parts of it that do that are where you can write them or get modules that are open source so it has the right hooks in place it would be like if you wanted to yeah have it have i don't know some sort of new feature that wasn't there i i like some new yeah or it goes or it goes deprecated and he does and the person doesn't release it open source and then
你知道某种新语言接管了并变得非常流行，就像现在 React 发生的那样，它是一个包含 HTML 等内容的 JSX 文件。如果类似的事情发生并真正开始流行，而你加入了一家公司，他们说“好吧，你必须编写这些 JSX 文件”，你知道，Sublime 不行，但它的部分功能是可以编写的，或者可以获得开源模块，所以它有正确的钩子。如果你想拥有某种以前没有的新功能，或者它被弃用了，而那个人没有将其开源，那么
like you can't maintain it but sublime came up because it was known for being really really fast for a graphical um editor yeah right it has some pretty cool features i like the little like this i was trying to describe i was doing a poor poor job of it yeah yeah it some pretty cool features. I like the little... Yeah, that's what I was trying to describe. I was doing a poor job of it. Yeah. Yeah, it's pretty cool. Another new kid on the block is Atom. I've actually been using Atom a lot lately. It's pretty awesome. So a couple of awesome things about Atom.
你就无法维护它。但 Sublime 的出现是因为它以图形化编辑器的速度非常快而闻名。是的，没错，它有一些非常酷的功能。我喜欢那个……我刚才试图描述它，但我做得不好。是的，是的，它有一些非常酷的功能。我喜欢那个……是的，那就是我试图描述的。我做得不好。是的，是的，它很酷。另一个新成员是 Atom。我最近实际上一直在使用 Atom。它非常棒。所以 Atom 有几件很棒的事情。
One is it works over SSH. So you can actually point it at a SSH repository, and you can edit files over SSH, and it just makes that experience completely painless. So it also has some kind of searching, which also works for the SSH. I don't know what sort of black magic is going on there, but the remote development is pretty amazing. It's also known for, I guess it's all written in javascript and so you
一个是它可以通过 SSH 工作。所以你可以把它指向一个 SSH 存储库，你可以在 SSH 上编辑文件，这让体验变得完全无痛。它还有某种搜索功能，也适用于 SSH。我不知道那里发生了什么黑魔法，但远程开发非常棒。它还以……我想它完全是用 JavaScript 编写的，所以你
can kind of see it's basically rendering we talked about this before i think a little it's an it's not called embedded but it's a like native javascript app so like it hooks in natively but it's all just running kind of javascript so you can see how it's choosing to do the rendering and then like alter it if you're so inclined so So it's saying it runs on Electron, which is one of the frameworks for building apps using JavaScript and web technologies. And it's made by the same people who make GitHub. That's right, yeah.
可以看到它基本上是在渲染……我们之前谈过这个，我想一点点。它不是所谓的嵌入式，而是一个原生的 JavaScript 应用程序。所以它原生挂钩，但它只是在运行 JavaScript，所以你可以看到它是如何选择进行渲染的，如果你有兴趣的话，可以修改它。所以它说它运行在 Electron 上，这是使用 JavaScript 和 Web 技术构建应用程序的框架之一。而且它是由制作 GitHub 的同一群人制作的。没错，是的。
And all of the sort of visual features of the editor are just HTML and CSS. So a ton of people have made themes like i like this uh and i'm totally forgetting the name but i have a certain theme in emacs that i really like and uh someone basically just cloned uh that yeah i should say almost all of these have themes even vi i don't know about emacs because i don't use it, but even in VI, you can find essentially themes for ways to kind of have it have a color scheme or palette that you like. But I do like the one that I guess initially,
编辑器的所有视觉功能都只是 HTML 和 CSS。所以很多人制作了主题，比如我喜欢这个……我完全忘了名字，但我有一个非常喜欢的 Emacs 主题，有人基本上只是克隆了那个。是的，我应该说几乎所有这些都有主题，甚至 VI 也有。我不知道 Emacs，因为我不使用它，但即使在 VI 中，你也可以找到本质上的主题，让你拥有喜欢的配色方案或调色板。但我确实喜欢那个我最初遇到的，
the first one I really encountered, it was in Sublime, that default color scheme that Sublime chose in dark. I really liked that. Yep, that's actually similar. I use Clarity, the Clarity color theme theme in emacs and it's also a dark theme in general i mean you can do whatever you want but i feel like dark themes are just way better on the eyes um you know so to just to explain dark theme is where is where the the
我在 Sublime 中遇到的第一个，Sublime 选择的那个默认深色配色方案。我真的很喜欢那个。是的，这实际上很相似。我在 Emacs 中使用 Clarity 配色主题，它通常也是一个深色主题。我的意思是你可以做任何你想做的事，但我感觉深色主题对眼睛更好。所以，解释一下，深色主题是指
background is or dark text is you know a bright color as opposed to what you're used to you know when you read things on the web or something like that so now some languages are built in together with their editors so this would be like matlab when you open up matlab you come right to like the console and you can start doing matlab operations or they have a file explorer built in to like operate on matlab projects it's not to say you can't write those in another editor but it they kind of ship their own and it isn't really meant to support things that aren't about matlab yeah right yep um there's r studio for r it's very similar um there's ipython notebook same kind of so i think more like spider would be like a python specific editor we should talk about ipython another time it's
背景是深色的，或者文本是明亮的颜色，而不是你习惯的那种（当你阅读网页时）。所以现在有些语言与它们的编辑器内置在一起。这就像 MATLAB，当你打开 MATLAB 时，你会直接进入控制台，你可以开始进行 MATLAB 操作，或者它们内置了一个文件资源管理器来操作 MATLAB 项目。这并不是说你不能在其他编辑器中编写这些代码，但它们自带了自己的编辑器，而且它并不真正打算支持与 MATLAB 无关的东西。是的，没错。是的，有用于 R 的 RStudio，非常相似。有 IPython Notebook，也是同样的情况。所以我认为像 Spyder 这样的更像是 Python 专用编辑器。我们应该下次再谈 IPython，它
called something else now ipython notebook oh yeah yeah jupiter which we should talk about because i've actually come across several instances of that now it's catching on a lot and i i really like this approach but i think more like spider or something which is and there are others that's a good point but so the point the the overall point here is when you're language specific then you can do some unique things like for example in matlab um there's a section of the editor where you can see all of the global variables and that only makes sense because you're writing in matlab like i mean they wouldn't be able to do that for every language well they it would just be you wouldn't typically find it because it'd be really hard to support yeah like i don't even know what that would mean i mean because like
现在叫别的名字了，IPython Notebook。哦，是的，Jupyter，我们应该谈谈它，因为我实际上已经多次遇到它了，它正在流行起来，我真的很喜欢这种方法。但我认为更像 Spyder 之类的，还有其他的，这是一个很好的观点。但总的来说，当你针对特定语言时，你可以做一些独特的事情。例如，在 MATLAB 中，编辑器的一部分可以看到所有的全局变量，这只有在你用 MATLAB 编写代码时才有意义。我的意思是，他们无法为每种语言都做到这一点。好吧，你通常不会发现它，因为它很难支持。是的，我甚至不知道那意味着什么，因为就像
if you have python and you had like a python console and you were you had variables you could have something tracking the current variables in scope yeah yeah and so so there is that there's a there's a qt ipython thing which is kind of like that but again that's like the editor is piped. Right but it would be harder to do that for like C++ like it would only make sense if you're currently debugging an application or Java
如果你有 Python，并且你有一个 Python 控制台，你有变量，你可以有某种东西来跟踪当前作用域内的变量。是的，是的，所以有一个 Qt IPython 的东西，有点像那样，但同样，编辑器是管道化的。没错，但为 C++ 做这件事会更难，只有当你正在调试应用程序或 Java 时才有意义。
Yeah exactly and so that's like one example but there's other things where like you know the editor can provide something that only works because it's running MATLAB. There are also lots of language-specific ones for the Lisp and functional languages as well. But I don't use them routinely enough
是的，完全正确。所以这是一个例子，但还有其他事情，比如编辑器可以提供一些只有在运行 MATLAB 时才有效的功能。对于 Lisp 和函数式语言，也有很多特定于语言的编辑器。但我没有经常使用它们，
to be up on what the best ways of using them are. So anytime you have the interactive prompt, things like Python, MATLAB, a lot of the lisps um have this closure has it um where you have it's you know a command prompt and you're typing stuff in and you can develop that way um you can do some interesting stuff with language specific features versus something that's compiled and run like java or c++ those features don't make a lot of sense for yeah right yep um so there's some editors that we've used in the past are no longer with us you know are dead yeah um so code blocks is one um code blocks was really cool before uh cmake
以至于了解使用它们的最佳方式。所以任何时候你有交互式提示符，像 Python、MATLAB，很多 Lisp，Clojure 也有，你有一个命令提示符，你在输入东西，你可以那样开发。你可以用特定于语言的功能做一些有趣的事情，而不是像 Java 或 C++ 那样编译和运行。那些功能对它们来说没有太大意义。是的，没错。所以有一些我们过去使用过的编辑器已经不在了，它们“死了”。是的，CodeBlocks 就是其中之一。CodeBlocks 在 CMake
and these other build systems came out. The thing about CodeBlocks was you had this CodeBlocks project, and under the hood, they would sort of figure out what to do if you're on Windows, if you're on Linux, if you're on Mac. And so you could just, like, I could take this CodeBlocks project with the source files and everything and copy it to someone who's running Windows, and they could just install it with CodeBlocks, and it would build a Windows program instead of a Mac program.
和其他构建系统出现之前真的很酷。CodeBlocks 的特点是你有这个 CodeBlocks 项目，在底层，如果你在 Windows、Linux 或 Mac 上，它们会弄清楚该做什么。所以你可以直接……我可以把这个带有源文件和所有内容的 CodeBlocks 项目复制给运行 Windows 的人，他们只需安装 CodeBlocks，它就会构建一个 Windows 程序而不是 Mac 程序。
That was super cool, but the cool part of that was actually the cross-platform Makefile system, not the editor. The editor was not that great. And so once CMake came came out it kind of torpedoed code blocks um another one is borland builder i actually never used this other than in school i only used this when they were teaching c++ did you ever use um i think very very limited like once or twice because it was like on a computer i used and i just wanted to try it out okay yeah so when we were learning c++ uh we learned on borland builder and it was like on a computer i used and i just wanted to try it out okay yeah so when we were learning c++ uh we learned on on borland builder and it was it was you know uh it was
那太酷了，但那其中酷的部分实际上是跨平台的 Makefile 系统，而不是编辑器。编辑器没那么好。所以一旦 CMake 出来，它就有点摧毁了 CodeBlocks。另一个是 Borland Builder，我实际上除了在学校里从未用过它，我只在他们教 C++ 时用过它。你用过吗？我想非常非常有限，用过一两次，因为它在我用的一台电脑上，我只是想试试。好的，是的，当我们学习 C++ 时，我们是在 Borland Builder 上学习的，它就在我用的一台电脑上，我只是想试试。好的，是的，当我们学习 C++ 时，我们是在 Borland Builder 上学习的，它……你知道……它
it was terrible but it it uh died a painful death and the other one is free basic i don't know uh what was your first language c patrick yeah really i mean i did some stuff in basic but like i kind of put like you know some stuff in basic but like a kind of like you know more like following examples and like making kind of play things a little bit in basic q basic oh yeah the first one i like really like learned and understood from like a language perspective with c okay i'm in the same way as you then so so actually for me it was c plus plus but but yeah so so basic was just kind of one that you know I just made like little dummy apps that I copied out of a book. And so I used Free Basic.
它很糟糕，但它死得很痛苦。另一个是 Free Basic。我不知道……你的第一门语言是 C 吗，Patrick？是的，真的吗？我的意思是，我做了一些 Basic 的东西，但就像……我有点像……你知道，更多的是跟随例子，在 Basic 中做一些小玩意。QBasic。哦，是的，我真正学习并从语言角度理解的第一个是 C。好的，我和你一样。所以对我来说是 C++。但是的，Basic 只是我从书上抄来的小演示程序。所以我用了 Free Basic。
But I mean, I'm not saying Free Basic is, like none of these are actually dead. You could probably get Borland Builder. And Codeblocks and Free Basic are still around, but they're just kind of dead to us. Actually, I had this book. It was like a choose your own adventure book um but to know what page to go next you have to enter in this free basic program on your computer and then run it and it
但我的意思是，我不是说 Free Basic 是……这些都不是真的死了。你可能还能弄到 Borland Builder。CodeBlocks 和 Free Basic 仍然存在，但它们对我们来说已经“死”了。实际上，我有一本书。它就像一本“选择你自己的冒险”书，但为了知道下一页去哪里，你必须在电脑上输入这个 Free Basic 程序，然后运行它，它
would tell you the answer it was so cool like i mean but you should just be able to do it in your head right or was it like so complicated that you couldn't no it was it was like a recursive function you couldn't yeah yeah but like uh you know the fact like you would type this in and then you'd hit go and it would i saw like python the hard way that sounds like basic the insane way yeah it was basically insane way um but yeah i mean that was that was pretty cool i wish they kind of did more like that where they integrated. I mean, now as adults, it's not interesting. But for kids, I think it would be great.
会告诉你答案。它太酷了，我的意思是……但你应该能够自己在脑子里做，对吧？还是说它太复杂了，你做不到？不，它就像一个递归函数，你做不到。但你知道，你输入这个，然后按“开始”，它就会……我看到了“Python the Hard Way”，那听起来像“Basic the Insane Way”。是的，它基本上是“Insane Way”。但是的，那真的很酷。我希望他们能做更多这样的事情，将它们集成在一起。我的意思是，现在作为成年人，这不有趣。但对于孩子，我认为这会很棒。
So you were saying that you did TypeScript in Eclipse. What else do you use when you write JavaScript? I don't write much JavaScript, so I don't really know. Oh, well, I've never done TypeScript in Eclipse. I know that there's a plug-in now. But all my JavaScript I've done using Emacs. I didn't know if there was a preferred way. I assume something like Atom is really
所以你说你在 Eclipse 中做了 TypeScript。你写 JavaScript 时还用什么？我不怎么写 JavaScript，所以我真的不知道。哦，好吧，我从来没在 Eclipse 中做过 TypeScript。我知道现在有一个插件。但我所有的 JavaScript 都是用 Emacs 做的。我不知道是否有首选方式。我假设像 Atom 这样的东西真的很
tailored to that because they flaunt that feature. Yeah, maybe. If you have a good... Write us in. If you write JavaScript day-to-day, tell us what you're using. Yeah, or anything. If you use JavaScript day-to-day, tell us what you're using. Yeah, or anything.
适合那个，因为他们炫耀那个功能。是的，也许吧。如果你有一个好的……写信给我们。如果你每天都写 JavaScript，告诉我们你在用什么。是的，或者任何东西。如果你每天都写 JavaScript，告诉我们你在用什么。是的，或者任何东西。
If you use any editor we haven't mentioned, post on Facebook, post on the blog, post on G+, and things like that. Let us know. If there's something really cool, we'll do a follow-up on the show.
如果你使用我们没有提到的任何编辑器，在 Facebook 上发帖，在博客上发帖，在 G+ 上发帖，等等。让我们知道。如果有非常酷的东西，我们会在节目中跟进。
Yeah, we'll make a 12-minute show sponsored by someone else. Or sponsored is the wrong word featuring some other guests sponsored by you the patreon i don't know um so thanks everyone for listening our viewership continues to go up um we're we have some more interviews kind of scheduled but i think we're going to try to cut them down a little and and probably go to like uh something a little less frequent because we enjoy talking to you guys. And I realized like we've,
是的，我们会做一个由其他人赞助的 12 分钟节目。或者“赞助”这个词用错了，是由其他嘉宾出演，由你们 Patreon 赞助。我不知道。总之，感谢大家的收听，我们的收视率持续上升。我们还有一些采访计划，但我认为我们会尝试稍微减少一点，可能频率会低一点，因为我们喜欢和你们聊天。我意识到，
it's been, I think we had two episodes in a row that were interviews and I really had like a buildup of like tools of the show and books I wanted to share. So we're going to probably try to get, you know, hearing the normal flow of the episode a little more frequently. Yeah, totally.
我想我们连续两集都是采访，我真的积累了很多想分享的节目工具和书籍。所以我们可能会尝试……听到正常的节目流程频率更高一点。是的，完全同意。
Totally. I mean, there's so many more language i'm dying to learn julia that's oh my one i've been working on is elm oh i've never heard of elm okay so we definitely have two two really cool shows all right till next time see you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you
完全同意。我的意思是，还有很多语言，我渴望学习 Julia。哦，我一直在研究的是 Elm。哦，我从没听说过 Elm。好的，所以我们肯定有两期非常酷的节目。好的，下次见，回头见。片头音乐是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你
must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
必须提供对 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。